[Musique]
on va laisser entrer les derniers
chers collègues mesdames et messieurs
je suis
particulièrement heureux d'ouvrir cette
première réunion de
commission de la session ordinaire 2022
2023 par une table ronde table ronde
consacrée aux enjeux liés au
développement du véhicule électrique
comme vous le savez bien le secteur des
transports est le premier secteur
émetteur de gaz à effet de serre en
France puisqu'il représente 32% des
émissions
le monde entier et le monde routier
comprenant à la fois les véhicules
légers et poids lourds et responsables
depuis 90% des émissions c'est pourquoi
nous sommes dotés d'objectifs ambitieux
de réduction des émissions de CO2 mais
aussi de particules fines liées aux
transports routier l'article 73 de la
loi d'orientation des mobilités telles
que modifiée par l'article 103 de la loi
climat et résilience prévoit ainsi la
fin de la vente de véhicule et voiture
particulière neuve émettant plus de 123g
de dioxyde de carbone par km d'ici 2030
à l'échelle européenne le test de
régularité de régulation des émissions
de CO2 des automobiles est en cours de
discussion le Conseil de l'Union
européenne c'est notamment prononcé en
faveur de l'interdiction à partir de
2035 de la vente de véhicule neuf à
moteur essence ou diesel dans ce
contexte véhicule électrique constitue
un important levier levier de
décarbonation du transport routier
d'après une étude de 2017 réalisée par
la Fondation pour la Nature et l'Homme
et la Fondation européenne pour le
climat en lien avec la dame en France
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
induite par la fabrication l'usage et la
fin de vie d'un véhicule électrique
serait deux à trois fois inférieur à
celle du véhicule essence et diesel
c'est un pacte climatique du véhicule
électrique dépend néanmoins de nombreux
autres facteurs
facteurs comme le mix énergétique
l'efficacité des modes de production des
véhicules des capacités et c'est
important de recyclage ainsi que
l'extraction des métaux nécessaires à la
fabrication des batteries
avec bien entendu des pollutions
générées dans d'autres pays nous aurons
sans doute l'occasion sur ce point d'y
revenir au cours de notre débat en outre
et à l'heure du déploiement des zones
faibles émissions Les ZFM en
agglomération les véhicules électriques
présentent l'avantage de ne pas émettre
de polluantes atmosphérique en roulant
ils ne sont à ce type pas concernés par
d'éventuelles restrictions de
circulation la vente de véhicules
électriques les ventes de véhicules
électriques ont ainsi fortement
progressé ces dernières années d'après
la guerre France dont nous recevons le
délégué général la mobilité électrique
connaît une forte dynamique avec plus de
000 véhicules électriques immatriculées
au cours de l'année 2021
pour autant le développement des
véhicules électriques soulève
d'importantes questions
pour y répondre nous avons le plaisir
d'accueillir Jean-Philippe Bonnet
directeur adjoint au pôle stratégie
prospective et évaluation art
madame Sandrine Bouvier directeur de du
programme mobilité électrique à Stella
this Monsieur Olivier David chef du
service climat et efficacité énergétique
au sein de la Direction générale de
l'énergie et du climat au ministère de
la transition énergétique Monsieur
Pierre de Firma directeur du programme
mobilité électrique de nedis Monsieur
Nicolas Tcheng chargé d'affaires
publiques de Renault monsieur Clément
molizon délégué général de la vers
France je me permettrai simplement
d'évoquer quelques questionnements
avant de vous laisser et bien sûr la
parole pour un avant-propos à l'échange
avec les membres de la commission ma
première question concerne la capacité
du réseau électrique à accueillir la
montée en puissance rapide du nombre de
véhicules à recharger
en effet dans les prochaines années RTL
le gestionnaire du réseau de transport
d'électricité publié en 2017 un bilan
prévisionnel confirmé par une étude de
2019 qui montre que le système
électrique sera en mesure d'accueillir
le développement des véhicules
électriques monsieur bonnet
pourriez-vous nous indiquer si c'est
prévisions sont susceptibles d'être
révisés compte tenu des risques je vous
donnera peut-être tenu des risques de
pénurie que nous rencontrons dans le
contexte de crise actuelle j'en viens
ensuite au déploiement des bornes borne
de recharge qui est l'une des conditions
sinequanone du développement de la
mobilité électrique l'objectif de
déployer 100000 bornes de recharge
ouvert au public à la fin de l'année
2021 n'a pas encore été atteint puisque
seulement 53000 points de recharge avait
été installé au 31 décembre 2021 je
m'adresse à présent aux représentants de
nedis et de la vers France pourriez-vous
dresser un état des lieux de la
situation à la fois les bornes de
recharge public et des bornes de
recharge privées en précisant aussi si
les différents types de points en
précisant aussi les différents types de
points de recharge pourriez-vous
également nous préciser qu'elles sont
d'après vous les obstacles à lever pour
accélérer leur déploiement
le processus de fabrication des
véhicules électriques est aussi source
de nombreuses interrogations les
objectifs sont ambitieux certains
d'entre eux sont d'ailleurs déclinés
dans le contrat stratégique de filière
aussi et ma question s'adresse plus
particulièrement aux représentant de
Renault Estelle antis nous souhaiterions
savoir d'une part si les constructeurs
estiment être en capacité de produire un
grand nombre de véhicules à court terme
et d'autre part quelles sont les
problématiques spécifiques à la
fabrication des ce véhicule mais
également et c'est important alors
recyclage en particulier pourriez-vous
faire un point sur la question de la
production des batteries
à grande échelle déploiement du véhicule
électrique supposant fin une certaine
acceptabilité
acceptabilité sur l'offre de véhicule
leur autonomie le maillage du territoire
en infrastructure de recharge et le coût
de la recharge mais aussi le prix du
véhicule lui-même il s'agit d'une
question absolument cruciale puisque le
prix d'un véhicule électrique reste à ce
statut supérieur à celui d'un véhicule
thermique la prime à la conversion et le
bonus écologique sont des outils
concourant à bien diminuer le surco en
parallèle le rapporteur du projet de loi
climat et résilience Philippe Tabarro
soutenu à l'unanimité avait souhaité
créer un prêt à taux zéro pour
l'acquisition de véhicules peu polluants
qui figure désormais à l'article 107 du
texte en août le projet de loi de
finance pour 2023 prévoit le lancement
d'un leasing social pourriez-vous
Monsieur David en détailler les
modalités et plus globalement revenir
sur les modalités d'aide à l'acquisition
des véhicules électriques
j'essaie d'après à présent la parole
nous intervenants pour un propos
liminaire de 4 minutes afin que chacun
fasse le point dans son domaine de
compétence sur les enjeux du
développement du véhicule électrique et
sur les éventuels difficultés
rencontrées quant à son développement et
je vais donner la parole à Monsieur
bonnet représentant de RTL
merci monsieur le Président je crois que
vous avez posé tous les tous les enjeux
RTU le réseau transport d'électricité
sur l'exploitation du réseau à haute et
très haute tension
garantit l'équilibre entre l'offre et la
demande à tout moment en matière
d'électricité en ce qui concerne le
véhicule électrique nous notre
enjeu principal c'est celui de la
question des questions globales des
enjeux globaux par rapport au système
électrique vous avez bien posé que se
passe-t-il si nous avons demain 5 10 20
35 millions de véhicules électriques en
circulation est-ce que le système
électrique sera en mesure de satisfaire
la demande d'électricité
nous abordons cette question sous
plusieurs angles l'équilibre offre de
demande je l'ai dit à la fois en énergie
en puissance toujours important de
regarder ces deux aspects j'y reviendrai
et puis aussi du point de vue du réseau
que nous exploitons mais de ce point de
vue là nous sommes clairement en
deuxième ligne c'est bien enedis et les
entreprises locales de distribution qui
sont en charge de raccorder les bornes
de recharge des véhicules électriques
il y a j'y reviendrai également
vous l'avez souligné nous avons publié
une étude en 2019 une étude approfondie
sur sur cette question
que vous trouvez sur sur Internet qui a
été réalisé en collaboration avec la
vert pour répondre à cette question
qu'on voyait monter sans doute beaucoup
instrumentalisée par les opposants
véhicules électriques étaient est-ce que
le développement du véhicule électrique
va faire s'effondrer le système
électrique à plus ou moins long terme
la réponse est clairement rassurante
vous l'avez dit et cette étude de 2019
fournit un centre d'éléments que je
rappellerai ici alors il faut avoir en
tête qu'elle est limitée à l'horizon
2035 qu'on est en 2019
à cette époque là nous avions travaillé
sur des scénarios qui prévoyaient entre
7 et 16 millions de véhicules légers
électriques en circulation à l'horizon
à cette horizon là nos
perspectives que nous dressions étaient
plutôt décevante pour les pour les pour
les catastrophes puisque l'énergie
totale à mobilisé
peut apparaître relativement modéré pour
pour 4 millions de véhicules on est sur
sur 10 terawatters pour 16 millions dans
les scénarios on est sur 30 à 40
terawattheure la France
produisait à cette époque là dehors de
500 terawatt-heure c'est c'est l'ordre
de grandeur de notre production notre
consommation d'électricité
et en termes de puissance
là nous émettions quelques quelques
mises en garde à savoir que si on ne
faisait rien si on laissait s'installer
des habitudes de recharge dites
naturelles à savoir je rentre chez moi
le soir après une journée de travail je
mets mon véhicule à charger
immédiatement entre 18h et 20h nous
pourrions avoir à faire face à des pics
de puissance relativement important de
l'ordre de 6 à 8 GW ce qui pourrait
représenter au printemps ou dans la
mi-saison de l'ordre de 15 à 20% de la
puissance appelée sur le réseau bon pour
autant nous sommes convaincus que des
systèmes simples
reposant sur l'intelligence de nos
concitoyens permettrait de lisser
fortement ses appels de puissance ne
serait-ce que voilà des questions des
systèmes basés sur les heures pleines
heures creuses qui sont bien connus tous
les Français qui sont utilisés
aujourd'hui pour le fonctionnement des
chauffe-eau électrique par exemple
permettrait de limiter cet appel de
puissance à 2 à 4 gigawatts en pointe et
donc serait tout à fait absorbable par
le système électrique
on est même allé plus loin en
considérant que si était mise en place
des dispositifs de pilotage fin alors
qu'ils font appel à des technologies de
pilotage des bandes de recharge voire
même des capacités des véhicules à
restituer l'électricité au réseau le
véhicule électrique pourrait apporter
une contribution au système électrique
et fournir 1 à 2 gigawatts de puissance
au moment où le réseau on a besoin voilà
ça suppose des développements
technologiques assez spécifiques nous
avions aussi regarder la question des
grands départs c'était un sujet qui
agitait pas mal de gens grand départ en
été grand départ avant les vacances de
Noël l'ont conclu qui pourrait y avoir
effectivement des appels de puissance
importante mais que il serait gérable un
peu plus compliqué peut-être à Noël
parce qu'on est en période hivernale ou
le chauffage électrique appelle aussi
pas mal de puissance mais rien de rien à
surmontable
ces données ces analyses là ont été
réactualisées dans le rapport publié en
2021 fin 2021 sur les futurs
énergétiques un rapport ambitieux qui
qui vise adresser ce que le pourrait
être un système électrique totalement
décarboné à l'horizon 2050
et nous avons travaillé sur des
scénarios ou à l'horizon 2050 la France
pourrait compter jusqu'à 36 millions de
véhicules légers avec beaucoup
d'incertitudes sur les véhicules lourds
je pense que d'autres intervenants ils
reviendront qui nous a fait considérer
un scénario où les véhicules lourds
seraient aussi électrifiés et là on
pourrait avoir besoin de 80 à 100 tt
d'énergie pour alimenter la mobilité
pour alimenter les transports
ce qui est relativement important
mais qui représente la moitié de la
hausse des besoins en électricité
envisagés pour l'ensemble de la France à
cet horizon là
en ce qui concerne les enjeux de
flexibilité
ils sont
variables en fonction des choix qui
seront faits sur le mix de production
dans les scénarios comptant beaucoup
d'énergie renouvelables il faudrait
pouvoir compter sur une automatisation
plus poussée des véhicules électriques
pour que ils profitent des périodes de
production des énergies renouvelables et
qui puissent apporter une contribution
au bon fonctionnement du réseau dans des
scénarios avec une part de nucléaire
plus importante ses besoins de
flexibilité seraient moins important
également
sur les questions que vous avez soulevé
de risque de pénurie je crois que les
enseignements de ce rapport qui ont été
publiés en octobre dernier donc avant
que vraiment la crise d'émerge
brutalement sur sur la scène
internationale et française je pense que
cette crise que nous connaissons ne
remet pas en cause ces orientations
le rapport avait pour objectif de
dresser le tableau d'un système
électrique décarboné donc d'une sortie
totale des énergies fossiles dans tous
les secteurs de notre activité je crois
que la volatilité des prix des énergies
fossiles montrent que c'est une c'est un
impératif de souveraineté énergétique en
ce qui concerne les difficultés que
connaît aujourd'hui le parc nucléaire
français elles étaient aussi soulignées
dans le rapport vieillissement de ce
parc et le rapport conclué à l'urgence à
prendre des décisions pour garantir le
renouvellement de notre système
électrique et le développement d'un parc
qui soit apte à accompagner la stratégie
nationale bas carbone et la
décarbonation de tous les usages dont le
transport
je terminerai pour dire un mot sur le
réseau je l'ai dit les besoins de
consommation sont diffus répartis sur
tout le territoire
enedis et les gestion de réseau de
distribution sont en première ligne les
besoins éventuels d'adaptation du réseau
de transport se traiteront dans le cas
du dialogue habituel entre de
coordination entre les deux
gestionnaires de réseau
il pourrait y avoir des questions
peut-être très ponctuelles sur des aires
d'autoroutes des besoins de puissance
importants nécessitant des
infrastructures spécifiques nous sommes
en discussion avec un certain nombre de
de concessionnaire autoroutier et puis
il y a la question des des
usines des gigafactory de fabrication de
batterie ou même de recyclage des
batteries pour lequel il existe
plusieurs projets sur le territoire
français et là cela fait appel à des
puissances importantes et c'est bien RTE
qui est en contact avec les opérateurs
de ses usines pour en assurer le
raccordement et fournir l'électricité
voilà monsieur le Président merci et ben
je vais donner la parole aux
représentants de nudisme monsieur Firma
vous avez la parole dans 4 minutes
merci Monsieur le monsieur le Président
effectivement donc je peux compléter un
petit peu pour la partie distribution ce
qui vient d'être dit sur la capacité du
réseau ce que l'on ce que l'on constate
aujourd'hui et c'est déjà c'est déjà
important puisque on le dira tout à
l'heure mais il y a un million de
véhicules électriques déjà en France
rechargeable et on a via une enquête que
nous conduisons
et dont nous allons sortir le la
nouvelle édition dans les prochains
jours on a une vision assez complète des
habitudes de recharge de ces de ces
possesseurs de véhicules électriques sur
un panel de 1000 donc qui est assez
représentatif de des possesseurs actuels
de véhicules électriques et ce que l'on
constate ces deux choses importantes
pour venir éclairer un peu ces ce que
l'on a dit sur la capacité du réseau
c'est que à
89%, ils n'ont pas plus besoin
d'augmenter la puissance souscrite de
leur abonnement pour alimenter le point
de charge à domicile dont ils ont dont
ils ont besoin donc c'est à dire que
j'allais dire naturellement
illoge le moment de recharge
dans des périodes de temps où les autres
usages de l'horlogements n'est pas ne
sont pas ne consomment pas trop
ça c'est un c'est un premier point et
mais on y reviendra parce que ceux-ci
concerne très majoritairement les foyers
français qui vivent en maison
individuelle dans notre dans notre
enquête et c'est pas une surprise mais
88%
du panel habite en maison individuelle
tout simplement parce que c'est plus
compliqué pour les foyers ils sont 44%
des Français qui vivent en habitat
collectif d'avoir de trouver des
solutions de recharge j'y viendrai dans
deux minutes mais pour revenir sur le
sur la capacité du réseau ce que l'on
donc première bonne nouvelle de façon
assez naturelle il y a une j'allais dire
une
modalité d'usage à domicile en tout cas
des foyers pour justement éviter de
d'augmenter la puissance souscrite et
l'usage déjà très répandu à plus de 56%
les recharges se font en soirée ou la
nuit donc il y a déjà
ce cette adoption des heures creuses qui
est déjà relativement important de façon
naturelle et quand on regarde les études
que qu'on avait faites évidemment en
cohérence avec les scénarios de RTE
jusqu'à l'horizon 2050 ce qu'on voit
c'est que
si jamais on ne faisait rien il y aurait
un pic de consommation qui aujourd'hui
d'à peu près 80 gigawatts c'est à dire
80 gigawatts c'est la puissance maximum
appelée sur le réseau de distribution
aujourd'hui un soir d'hiver vers 19h
quoi et bien si on ne faisait rien ce
pic pourrait augmenter de
12% un circuit s'établirait à 89
gigawatt mais avec le pilotage de la
recharge et derrière cette locution il
faut pas voir forcément des choses très
sophistiquées ce qu'on vient de dire sur
les heures creuses va faire l'essentiel
du va faire l'essentiel du gain en
réalité ce qu'on voit c'est qu'avec un
des systèmes de pilotage de la recharge
répandue on réduit à zéro
cette augmentation du pic de charge dans
les scénarios qu'on a qu'on a projeté
c'est-à-dire qu'on a un pic de charge
toujours l'hiver vers 19h mais qui
resterait à peu près à 80 GW
alors
sur le
sur le rôle d'enedis effectivement
enedis comme comme tous les
gestionnaires de distribution du réseau
de distribution publique en France à un
rôle à un rôle central
bon le nôtre est prépondérant dans la
mesure où on couvre 95% du territoire
central puisque même si c'est une
lapalissade mais tous ces véhicules
électriques et dans nos estimations en
2035 on aurait 17 millions de véhicules
électriques rechargeables c'est sûrement
plus ou c'est sûrement moins qui
arrivera comme tous les scénarios
prospectifs mais bon voilà ça c'est le
Seigneur de référence qu'on a jusqu'à
maintenant et bien tous ces véhicules
électriques ils auront besoin ils ont
déjà besoin de points de charge et ces
points de charge il faudra qu'il soit
connecté au réseau de distribution
directement ou indirectement tous
et que ce réseau amène la la l'énergie
nécessaire au moment où elle est
demandée avec la puissance nécessaire
donc effectivement on est un peu au
centre au centre de cette de cet enjeu
de d'électrification du transport
d'ailleurs pour enedis
la transition écologique la
décarbonation de l'économie c'est deux
enjeux majeurs le raccordement des
producteurs d'énergie renouvelables au
réseau de distribution et puis
l'électrification des
usages mais principalement celle du
transport puisque c'est
l'électrification du transport qui va
tirer la croissance de la consommation
et aussi la croissance de la demande en
puissance appelée localement
donc on a vous disiez il faut distinguer
les cas de charge les cas de bornes on
peut déjà dire que on parle très souvent
des bornes accessibles au public
effectivement c'est un maillon essentiel
de la de l'infrastructure à déployer de
recharge bon je laisserai Clément dire
où on en est précisément sur ce point
moi je vais plutôt
d'abord dire que
cette partie là reste la partie
minoritaire puisque l'essentiel de
l'équipement se fait en milieu privé
comme je le disais tout à l'heure
88% des personnes de notre panel se
recharge à domicile et presque
exclusivement à domicile et donc
on a d'ailleurs au printemps
indiqué que on avait passé selon nos
estimations en France le million de
points de charge puisque il y a les
les points de charge accessibles au
public mais il y a aussi tous les autres
en milieu privé à domicile etc alors les
principaux enjeux
pardon les principaux enjeux de
l'équipement en infrastructure de
recharge vue de vue du réseau de
distribution c'est à domicile mais pour
le résidentiel collectif donc ça c'est
un segment qui a été identifié de longue
date par les pouvoirs publics comme
vraiment un segment clé dans lequel il
fallait libérer l'équipement et on sait
bien que ce qui fait difficulté c'est la
décision en assemblée générale de
copropriétaires pour les copropriétés
d'un équipement c'est-à-dire d'un
investissement en réalité qui va
m'intéresser au départ qu'une minorité
de copropriétaires d'où la difficulté de
prendre la décision et bien il y a un
dispositif maintenant qui était prévu
dans la loi l'homme et dont un décret
vient d'être publié qui permet à la
copropriété elle peut choisir une
solution privée en confiance
l'infrastructure collective à un
opérateur mais elle peut aussi
choisir la solution publique et
maintenant avec ce décret une solution
publique préfinancée ce qui permet de
mettre à zéro le reste à charge pour la
copropriété et ainsi de faciliter la
prise de décision la le financement
ensuite de cette infrastructure
collective sera assurée par les quotas
des différents copropriétaires qui
choisiront de s'y raccorder
ça c'est l'enjeu principal il va falloir
conclure parce que oui
collègues puissent vous poser des
questions bien entendu je voulais juste
simplement dire un mot sur les
autoroutes parce que effectivement le
deuxième frein à l'adoption du véhicule
électrique pour le véhicule principal et
bien c'est la peur de la panne sèche on
va dire ça comme ça et donc il faut
absolument que les les longs trajets
puissent être entrepris par les foyers
français qui font ce choix avec leur
famille dans leur voiture et donc il y a
une première phase d'équipement sous
l'impulsion des pouvoirs publics des
équipements entiers et enedis à jouer
aussi son rôle des 400 heures de service
d'autoroute qui va arriver à son terme
au début de l'année prochaine c'est une
première étape et on a pour aussi
rebondir sur ce que vous disiez on a
fait les études qui montrent les besoins
en puissance qu'on aura sur les quatre
sur chacune de ces 400 heures
d'autoroute en 2028 2035 et là aussi
bonne nouvelle c'est pas des travaux
pharaoniques il faut anticiper il faut
bien se coordonner avec les aménageurs
mais voilà c'est c'est tout à fait
envisageable merci je vais donner la
parole à votre voisin à Monsieur molison
pour déléguer général de la vert
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs
permettez-moi de vous remercier déjà
pour cette invitation et à travers nous
les 200 30 adhérents que l'on représente
notamment des constructeurs automobiles
des énergéticiens des installateurs
opérateurs et fabricants de bornes de
recharge et au-delà de notre qualité
d'association professionnelle nous
sommes également pilote et porteurs
depuis 2016 d'un programme de certificat
d'économie d'énergie à devenir qui
finance des infrastructures de recharge
et également fait de la sensibilisation
et de la formation pour le grand public
et certaines et certaines cibles le
développement de la de la mobilité
électrique de notre point de vue il est
lié au constat de l'urgence climatique
et de la nécessité de décarbonée nos
transports et la mobilité électrique
apparaît aujourd'hui comme une solution
à la fois crédible mature disponible
pour nous permettre d'atteindre la
neutralité carbone de réduire nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre mais
également d'améliorer la qualité de
l'air et de réduire la pollution
on voit que la dynamique est enclenchée
au niveau européen sur le second
semestre on avait déjà second trimestre
pardon on avait déjà près de 10% des
véhicules
immatriculés qui étaient électrique en
France également on a une dynamique qui
est bien amorcée depuis plusieurs mois
déjà on ne Cie entre 17 et 20% de parts
de marché chaque mois on a
99580 14 véhicules électrifiés très
précisément donc électrique et hybride
rechargeable le seul mois de septembre
c'est 36000 véhicules qui ont été
immatriculés donc on a une progression
de 10% depuis janvier par rapport à la
même période en 2021
vous nous interrogez sur les bornes de
recharge et leur déploiement là
également on voit qu'un qu'une dynamique
forte a été engagée au 30 septembre 2022
et ça c'est grâce au baromètre que l'on
publie tous les mois avec le ministère
de la transition énergétique nous
comptions 71 630 points de recharge
ouvert au public par l'ouverture au
public on entend notamment les points de
recharge en voirie sur autoroute et
également dans les parkings de centre
commerciaux ou des parkings de certaines
entreprises ça représente une évolution
de près de 50% sur les 12 derniers mois
donc c'est 18000 points de recharge qui
ont déjà été installés cette année c'est
presque autant que l'an dernier et à
titre de comparaison c'est presque
autant qu'entre 2016 et 2020
une dynamique particulière que l'on
constate c'est le développement de la
recharge rapide aujourd'hui en France
90% des recharges sont dites normales à
savoir inférieur à 22 kW mais on voit la
recharge rapide ultra rapide se
développer puis le début de l'année on a
triplé les points de recharge à très
haute puissance ultra rapide donc
supérieur à 150 kW c'est notamment lié à
l'équipement des autoroutes cet été déjà
60% des aires de services étaient
équipés en point de recharge rapide et
on a un objectif d'ici la fin de l'année
de 100%
enfin on s'est prêté à un exercice de
prospective pour essayer de quantifier
nos besoins à horizon 2025 et 2030
d'après la revue de littérature que l'on
a pu faire on aurait entre 165
000 et 215000 points de recharge ouvert
au public nécessaire à horizon 2025 et
entre 330 000 et 480 000 horizon 2030 à
cela il faudra ajouter entre 48 000 et
65000 points de recharge pour les
transports lourds notamment camions bus
et également les utilitaires légers mais
ceux-ci seront principalement des
recharges au dépôt
pour finir de notre de notre point de
vue quatre axes principaux doivent être
doivent être explorées dans les
prochaines années pour s'assurer que la
mobilité électrique puisse répondre aux
enjeux qu'on lui demande d'une part
éviter la fracture sociale en
accompagnant une réduction des coûts et
donc rendre la mobilité électrique
accessible au plus grand nombre d'autre
part développer la recharge public mais
privé on l'a rappelé à 90% des recharges
ont lieu chez soi ou au travail
informer et sensibiliser à la fois les
particuliers et les professionnels on le
fait dans le cadre d'advenir mais il y a
également des besoins énormes
aujourd'hui d'informations et enfin
accélérer l'électrification du transport
l'or et de la logistique urbaine en lien
notamment avec le déploiement des zones
à faible émission mobilité je vous
remercie
merci je vais vous donner les dernières
paroles représentant de Renault et ou
comme vous voulez ou de l'anis comme
vous voulez allez-y très bien monsieur
le Président je tiens avant toute chose
à vous remercier pour votre invitation
lesifications est probablement la brique
la plus importante pour l'avenir du
groupe silentis et la mobilité de nos
clients
c'est un axe majeur de développement
durable avec notre notre plan
stratégique dervorward nous nous
engageons à la Neutra la neutralité
carbone en 2038 et pour répondre à votre
question de capacité nous prévoyons deux
objectifs principaux la réduction de
notre empreinte carbone de 50 % et
surtout la vente de 100 % de nos
véhicules particuliers neufs en 100%
électrique en Europe en 2030 soit 5 ans
avant l'objectif fixé par la Commission
européenne cet engagement plein pot dans
l'électricité dans l'électro mobilité
pour reprendre le propos de notre
président Carlos Tavares implique une
transformation profonde
la batterie d'un véhicule électrique
représente environ 40% de son prix pour
reprendre les problématiques de coût que
vous évoquiez juste
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
investi très tôt dans des gigafactory
afin de produire ces batteries en France
en Allemagne et en Italie soit des
investissements de plus de 7 milliards
d'euros
avec notre JV assez C dans les
Hauts-de-France à Douvrin nous
commencerons la production des fins 2023
en cohérence de notre fort ancrage en
France nous aurons ainsi une gigafactory
de technologie française qui fabriquera
les cellules nécessaires à la
sécurisation de notre chaîne valeur et
permettra notre capacité à produire ces
véhicules
les investissements et prévisions
d'investissement de l'électrification et
les software s'élève à plus de 30
milliards d'euros entre 2021 et 2025
nous avons la volonté de sécuriser
l'approvisionnement des matériaux
critiques d'où l'engagement de
différents partenariats comme par
exemple l'entrée au capital de
l'entreprise Vulcan qui développe des
projets d'extraction en Allemagne et
peut-être demain en Alsace
cette démarche met d'ailleurs importante
pour l'État français la sécurisation de
filières en matière première critique
pour l'électro mobilité
au-delà de la mise en place et de la
mise en oeuvre d'un plan stratégique
notre groupe démontre son leadership
dans la transition énergétique du marché
français pour preuve depuis janvier 2022
c'était l'anti c'est numéro 1 de
l'électrification en France avec 31% de
parts de marché des véhicules
particuliers et utilitaires âgés en 100%
électrique et hybride rechargeable
un Français sur 5 se déclare prêt à
sauter le pas du véhicule électrique
motivé par le coup du carburant et le
souhait de faire des économies cependant
74% d'entre eux ont pour frein le coût
d'achat et l'autonomie
ainsi se pose la question de
l'accompagnement de nos clients français
et de leur rythme et du rythme de mise
en oeuvre dans vos territoires il leur
ZFE nous sommes donc confrontés aux
problématiques d'accessibilité à ces
véhicules et à la maîtrise du coût
d'énergie et de sa provenance c'est
pourquoi nous avons lancé cet été une
offre innovante avec un loyer modéré et
un loyer contenu de 110 euros par mois
puis une facturation à l'usage pour les
clients et les gîtes à la prière à la
conversion dans cette logique de
remplacement du parc roulant
et c'est aussi pourquoi une fiscalité
avantageuse aide à accélérer cette
transition énergétique tant pour les
entreprises que pour les autres que pour
les particuliers
aux enjeux financiers s'ajoutent les
enjeux technologiques je citerai
l'hybride rechargeable qui pour nous est
une transition est une technologie de
transition parfaite pour changer les
usages de nos concitoyens et de nos
clients l'hydrogène à la base de nos
fourgons véhicules électrifiés de taille
moyenne nous lancerons nous avons lancé
déjà pour nos marques Peugeot Citroën
Opel des véhicules à pile à combustible
et le lancement de nouvelles plateformes
qui vont nous permettre de lancer plus
de 60 modèles 100% électrique d'ici 2030
en Europe et assumer cette capacité de
transition énergétique je soulignerai
pour reprendre les propos de mes prises
l'importance des infrastructures de
densifier le nombre de stations
d'hydrogène de couvrir les zones
blanches et d'augmenter le nombre de
points de bornes publiques
de continuer à promouvoir les wall box
pour promouvoir programmer au bon moment
la recharge rapide aux heures adéquates
et enfin accompagner plus fortement les
copropriétés et l'engagement des
bailleurs sociaux pour se développements
cet éléphique cette électrification est
un défi pour ses lentilles mais aussi
pour notre pays plus largement pour
l'environnement c'était dentiste à
investi en quatre en quatre années deux
milliards d'euros dans son appareil
intrustriel français pour réaliser cette
transformation électrique avec l'aide
des régions et de l'État et l'appui de
l'ensemble des salariés qui portent le
défi de la performance
nous devons en effet demain être capable
de commercialiser ces véhicules
électriques à des prix comparables à
ceux du thermique afin d'offrir à nos
clients des solutions de mobilité propre
sur et abordables je vous remercie
monsieur le Président merci madame je
vais donner la parole aux représentant
de Renaud oui monsieur le Président
bonjour madame et messieurs merci
beaucoup pour cette invitation je vais
essayer de compléter ce qui a déjà été
dit et je m'inscris globalement
complètement dans la continuité de ce
qui a été dit comme vous le savez
Renault a déjà 10 ans d'expérience dans
le véhicule électrique et aujourd'hui
une gamme assez complète qui va de la
citadine aux utilitaires en 2021 le
groupe a présenté un nouveau plan
stratégique qui intitulé renolution et
qui accélère encore nos ambitions je
fais un peu le j'ai un peu le détailler
avec l'ambition de faire de Renaud une
marque 100% électrique pour les
véhicules particuliers de 2030 aussi je
vais beaucoup parler de Renault mais
sachez bien sûr que toutes nos marques
sont embarquées que par exemple alpine
aussi va devenir une marque 100%
électrique avec beaucoup de nouveaux
véhicules dont déjà certains annoncé
comme étant produit dans notre usine
historique à Dieppe trois axes
prioritaires que je vais essayer
rapidement de vous présenter
premier axe en créant en France une
production décarbonée des véhicules
électriques et la valeur ajoutée dans
notre dans nos territoires deuxième axe
développer des services innovants de
nouvelle mobilité électrique et puis
troisième axe amélioré en permanence le
bilan environnemental du véhicule
électrique avec des sujets de seconde
vie de recyclage des batteries que vous
avez évoqué en introduction monsieur le
Président
sur donc en créer dans les territoires
la production avec avec stellantise et
avec les représentants de la filière la
PFA nous voulons essayer de favoriser un
écosystème autour du véhicule électrique
qui embarque au maximum la filière
automobile française alors quelques
exemples de ce que Renault fait en
France on a créé un grand pôle autour
des usines de Douai Maubeuge et Ruitz
qu'on appelait électricity pour produire
tous nos nouveaux véhicules électriques
de marque Renault en France donc avec
des véhicules peut-être que vous avez vu
dans la presse qui vont arriver la
nouvelle R5 la nouvelle R4 etc des aussi
pour alliance et Renaud Nissan
Mitsubishi
la nouvelle Mégane Itech aussi que vous
commencez que vous voyez dans les rues
qui est donc un véhicule qui est
assemblé à Douai dont le moteur provient
de l'usine de Cléon près de Rouen qui
est notre grande usine de production de
véhicules de moteur électrique le
châssis vient du Mans donc c'est quand
même une belle réussite tricolore et
dans ce pôle électricité dans le Nord on
a annoncé l'implantation d'une
gigafactory en partenariat avec nvidjan
et aussi des activités liées au bac
batterie
tout ça ça demande une reconversion de
nos usines avec beaucoup d'ambition mais
aussi avec beaucoup de dialogues
sociales on a mis en place des campus
pour anticiper les besoins de formation
et accompagner les changements dans les
métiers
pour voilà pour développer ces nouvelles
compétences c'est fait bien sûr en
partenariat avec la filière et avec les
pouvoirs publics
on développe aussi en France des
activités liées à l'hydrogène en
Île-de-France avec notre entreprise qui
s'appelle yvia et qui vise à développer
des véhicules utilitaires électriques
avec des piles à combustibles hydrogène
voilà c'était quelques exemples de ce
que Renault fait en France sur les
services de nouvelles mobilité je
voudrais quand même que ce soit je vais
l'aborder très rapidement et je pense
que c'est un sujet important nous avons
créé une marque qui est dédiée à ça qui
s'appelle mobile eyes
qui doivent en fait proposer des
services de mobilité plutôt que de la
possession de véhicules automobile ce
qui augmente d'ailleurs les taux
d'utilisation des véhicules donc c'était
une marque qui conçoit des véhicules qui
sont dédiés alors en service
d'autopartage qu'on opère déjà vous avez
l'autopartage en libre-services dans les
rues de Paris qui s'appelle City c'est
des types de service qui nécessitent de
s'adapter aux spécificités de chaque
territoire de travailler au plus près
des besoins avec les élucos avec les
services de l'État c'est une vraie
transformation pour notre industrie et
bien sûr nous on est en demande toujours
de lisibilité sur les ce qui se passe
dans les territoires notamment avec la
mise en place des ZFE je voulais aussi
vous dire que cette nouvelle marque
mobile eyes elle sera prête aussi dans
le domaine de l'énergie et que nous
voulons développer en fait des solutions
pour accompagner les particuliers les
entreprises et collectivités locales
pour avoir les bonnes solutions de en
charge adaptée à leurs besoins voilà à
la fois en conseil et en installation
troisième axe donc améliorer la
performance enfin la permanence le bilan
environnemental du véhicule électrique
on y travaille sur l'ensemble du cycle
de vie qui est déjà positif ou les
signaler monsieur le Président y compris
sur le transport de pièces le transport
des véhicules mais aussi la production
des batteries notre objectif c'est de
réduire de 20% l'empreinte carbone de la
batterie de la R5
donc en 2024 2025 par rapport à celle
actuelle de la Zoé et même de 35% en
les nouvelles batteries que nous
développons on les conçoit dès l'origine
pour être facilement réparable
réutilisable et recyclé je voudrais vous
signaler qu'à fin donc convertissons
tout une usine qui aujourd'hui produit
la Zoé le véhicule électrique historique
de Renault c'est une usine qui va être
très ambitieuse entièrement tournée
autour de l'économie circulaire donc
pour reconditionner des pièces mais
aussi des véhicules entiers pour
améliorer leur durabilité et leur
réutilisation et on développe à Flins
des activités liées aux batteries donc
des développements d'activités de
seconde vie ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que nous on comme nous avons été assez
pionniers survécu électrique on reçoit
des batteries de Zoé qui maintenant en
disant 15 ans il y a peu de
constructeurs qui ont cette chance là et
c'est des batteries qui en fait
conservent une capacité de charge très
importante à après une vie entière dans
un véhicule les batteries conservent
encore 75% de leur capacité de charge au
minimum et ça sur des batteries qu'on a
mis en service à 10 ans voilà donc on
est extrêmement heureux de ça et bien
sûr donc c'est des batteries qui
conservent une valeur extrêmement
importante après leur circulation et
donc on les réutilise avant de les
recycler on les réutilise de différentes
façons on pourra certainement revenir en
détail je vais pas avoir beaucoup de
temps là mais pour vous donner quelques
exemples par exemple dans des bateaux en
électrifie des bateaux on fait du
stockage stationnaire on fait voilà un
certain nombre d'activités dont je
pourrais vous bien sûr répondre à vos
questions dessus et toujours à Flins on
développe aussi des activités de
réparation puis de démantèlement des
batteries et nous avons signé des
partenariats avec des entreprises
françaises de Veolia notamment pour pour
créer une filière de recyclage avec
l'objectif en 2030 de réutiliser 80% des
matures des batteries dans la production
de nouvelles batteries
donc pour conclure je vais pas aller
trop loin par rapport à mon temps de
parole mais je voulais vous dire que
nous développons à la fois une gamme et
des services pour essayer de répondre à
un maximum d'usages et de situations
territoriales que le véhicule électrique
est bien sûr
se développe dans une logique
d'écosystème les besoins ont été
parfaitement expliqués précédemment
voilà donc je n'y reviendrai pas
sur la recharge sur les copropriétés
bien sûr aussi n'oublions pas poussons
les entreprises à renouveler leur flotte
c'est vraiment un sujet important ce
sont beaucoup les flottes d'entreprises
qui créent après le marché électrique
d'occasion pour les particuliers
je vous remercie Monsieur Merci pour
cette intervention je vais donner la
parole à Monsieur Olivier David le chef
du service climat et efficacité
énergétique vous avez la parole merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président Mesdames
Messieurs sénateurs merci pour votre
invitation mon intervention s'inscrira
dans en fait les interventions
précédentes on est sur un sujet le
développement du véhicule électrique
dans lequel on a toute une filière que
ce soit les gestionnaires de réseau
les constructeurs mais aussi un grand
nombre d'acteurs comme les collectivités
qui sont mobilisés pour le développement
de cette filière qui est très importante
pour l'atteindre de nos objectifs
climatiques vous le savez la loi énergie
climat 2019 et maintenant le règlement
européen prévoit un objectif de
neutralité carbone en 2050 qui implique
la fin d'utilisation des énergies
fossiles et donc notamment
les sens et le diesel utilisé dans les
véhicules majoritairement à l'heure
actuelle on observe un très fort
développement du véhicule électrique on
l'a dit dans les interventions
précédentes
au mois de septembre plus de 15% des
immatriculations en France sont de
l'électrique pure
et chaque mois
par rapport à l'année précédente le
nombre de véhicules électriques
immatrices neuf immatriculée augmente ce
qui est alors que on a une tendance de
on observe une tendance de diminution du
nombre de véhicules immatriculés bien
sûr
les règlements européens sont un driver
majeur de ce développement du véhicule
électrique vous l'avez cité en
introduction un règlement européen
oblige les constructeurs automobiles à
des objectifs contraignants des missions
des véhicules neufs qui sont
immatriculés chaque année et le nouveau
règlement européen qui est en cours de
discussion qui et adopté au conseil
en juin dernier et qui est a été
également adopté au Parlement et qui
fait actuellement l'objet d'un trilogue
prévoit la fin du véhicule thermique en
2035 dans des termes similaires au
Parlement et au conseil
pour accompagner le développement du
véhicule électrique l'État met en oeuvre
un série de dispositifs d'aide
c'est bien sûr des aides à l'achat du
véhicule électrique vous les avez cités
en introduction nos deux grands
dispositifs d'aide sont d'une part le
bonus et d'autre part la prime à la
conversion le bonus est ouvert à tous
les ménages
sans condition de revenus
c'est un bonus de 6000 euros quand on
achète un véhicule de moins de 47000
euros c'est-à-dire que progressivement
ce bonus a évolué
donc c'est un bonus de en supprimant du
bonus les lisibilité au bonus les
véhicules les plus chers à l'heure
actuelle on a un bonus de 6000 euros
pour les véhicules de moins de 47000
euros et un bonus de 2000 euros pour les
véhicules entre 47000 et 60 000 euros
c'est un dispositif de soutien qui
rencontre un grand succès puisqu'il y a
eu
plus de 170 000 bonus qui ont été
versées en 2021 et à l'heure actuelle
afin septembre 150 000 bonus ont déjà
été versés en 2022 notre deuxième grande
dispositif c'est la prime à la
conversion qui a pour objectif de de
donner une aide supplémentaire quand on
achète un véhicule mais qu'on met
également au rebut un véhicule ancien
c'est des véhicules critères 5 4 ou 3
l'objectif de la prime à la conversion
c'est bien de d'accélérer le
renouvellement du parc en mettant en
revue un véhicule ancien et en achetant
un véhicule notamment un véhicule
électrique
c'est aussi un dispositif qui a une
vocation sociale car si tous les ménages
sont éligibles à un prima la conversion
de 2500 euros pour l'achat d'un véhicule
électrique
ce la prime à la conversion est monte à
5000 euros pour les ménages et deux
premiers des cils et pour les gros
rouleurs là aussi c'est un dispositif
qui rencontre un grand succès depuis son
lancement en 2018
près de 850 000 primes à la conversion
ont distribué ensuite on a ces
disponible seront poursuivis en 2023
dans le programme dans le projet de la
finance 2023 1,3 milliards d'euros et
prévu pour ses dispositifs d'aide à la
chambre on a aussi des dispositifs
concentrés sur les ménages modestes on a
un crédit d'impôt excusez-moi
[Musique]
un prêt à taux zéro qui a été voté que
vous avez voté dans le
la loi climat et résilience qui comme le
prévoit la loi entrera en vigueur le 1er
janvier 2023 vous l'avez voulu pour une
durée expérimentale de deux ans
ce prêt à taux zéro le décret
d'application qui a été publié
je dirais couvre tout toutes les toutes
les possibilités ouvertes par la loi
puisqu'il sera ouvert à toutes les zones
à faible émission pour les ménages
modestes qui habitent dans les zones
après l'émission et qui travaillent dans
les zones à faible émission
on a un dispositif qui existe depuis
plusieurs années également de
microcrédit la réservée aux ménage
précaire pour les aider dans l'achat
d'un véhicule électrique on a également
un crédit d'impôt pour l'équipement
borne chez
les ménages qui achètent un véhicule
électrique c'est un crédit d'impôt de 75
% du prix de la borne à domicile dans la
limite de 300 euros
dans le soutien de l'État au véhicule
électrique il y a aussi un point
important qui est le soutien au borne on
en a beaucoup parlé mais le rapidement
gérer les trois grandes priorités de
l'État dans le soutien aux bornes c'est
d'une part les bornes ouvertes au public
avec un dispositif d'aide via le
programme C2E à devenir c'est également
les bornes en copropriété
enedis on a parlé il y a le nouveau
dispositif il y a un dispositif d'aide
via advenir qui prend en charge 50% des
coûts plus un certain nombre de
simplifications qui ont été votées sur
l'équipement des en copropriétés
l'équipement des bornes en copropriété
plus le dispositif on a parlé enedis
dont le décret vient d'être publié qui
permettra d'accélérer le développement
des bornes en copropriété et enfin notre
troisième priorité c'est le
développement d'un réseau de bornes de
recharge rapide sur le réseau routier
national 200 millions d'euros dans le
plan de relance sur les années 2021 et
2022 ont permis d'équiper toutes les
aires de services de bornes de recharge
rapide et
le plan France 2030 consacre 300
millions d'euros à
le développement de ce réseau de bornes
de recharge rapide voilà je serai pas
plus long je pense que j'ai largement
épuisé mon temps mais disponible pour
répondre à l'ensemble de vos questions
si à nos intervenants je les remercie
pour avoir respecté le temps de parole
j'ai donné la parole à Olivier Jacquin
merci beaucoup Président
je tiens à préciser vos questions est-ce
que vous pouvez indiquer à qui vous la
posez pour qu'on soit à peu près clair
pour que chacun réponde rapidement ce
qu'on a 15 15 interventions merci
parfait merci beaucoup président merci à
nos intervenants pour leur propos
absolument passionnants et toutes les
questions qui demeure
donc j'ai cinq questions la première
relative à ce que j'appelle le coup près
de 2035 avec la fin du thermique
avec les technologies électriques
actuelles il n'y a pas de solution
électrique qui permet une autonomie
acceptable et pertinente une véritable
économie une véritable autonomie donc on
a la solution que de faire des véhicules
très lourds ce qui est une aberration
absolue si on se réfère aux lois de la
physique et au fameux e = MC2 à tel
point qu'une start-up a imaginé des
chariots avec batterie additionnelle
pour les situations autoroutières donc
plutôt que ce coup près n'aurait-il pas
fallu une forte priorisation sur
l'électricité et réservé une
une
priorité du thermique sur certains au
pardon et de préserver réserver un peu
de thermique pour certains usages bref
un bouquet de solutions permettant au
milieu de gaz à l'hydrogène vers j'ai
bien insisté sur le verre et au
carburant alternatif n'aurait-il pu être
plus efficace ce bouquet plutôt que ce
couperait donc ce sera je sais pas à qui
on propose de distribuer les questions
elle plaît à tout le monde celle-là
vous verrez non elle va être prise
celle-ci la deuxième question c'est sur
la ressource en minerai je vous incite
chers collègues à dire l'interview
génial dans Le Parisien des deux PDG de
stellantis et Renault dans un dialogue
qui est assez intéressant et qui pose la
question que nous posons aujourd'hui et
donc
à un moment il répond de Carlo Tavares
sur la question du bilan carbone et du
poids des véhicules qui m'a beaucoup
intéressé
en gros je le cite il dit je me souviens
lorsque j'étais jeune ingénieur j'ai
fabriqué des voitures de segments B à
800 kg aujourd'hui les mêmes voitures du
segment B je les fabrique à une tonne 6
est-ce qu'on s'est posé la question de
savoir si l'écorce terrestre est capable
de fournir 800 kg de plus par véhicule
je me permets à ce moment-là d'évoquer
une visite récente que je viens de faire
à l'École des Mines de Nancy qui a un
lieu assez génial où m'a été présenté
par un chercheur un dispositif qui
mériterait d'être présenté ici c'est un
dispositif
pédagogique à l'intention du monde
politique des chercheurs et des citoyens
qui visent en développant des outils
numériques multi critères à faciliter la
prise de décision de l'ensemble des
acteurs tous les acteurs que j'ai cités
pour optimiser la sélection des produits
le chercheur est parti d'une affirmation
Tesla de vouloir tester il y a quelques
années une batterie avec un matériau
extrêmement rare il se dit mais c'est
une aberration complet et c'est comme ça
qu'il a inventé un dispositif qui
l'appelle dans un acronyme horrible
anglais Heroes
un dispositif extrêmement intéressant
qui mériterait d'être présenté ici donc
voilà ma question suivante
[Musique]
je souhaiterais ça va être beaucoup plus
court que nous fassions à un point sur
la Task Force sur la transition
énergétique du transport de marchandises
c'était plus le sujet de l'automobile
aujourd'hui mais peut-être qu'un ou
l'autre des intervenants à des
informations sur ce secteur qui est en
permanence oublié et il y a un lien
direct entre mes questions sur le poids
des véhicules et la problématique du
transport de marchandises et je vais
terminer avec la question du
du poids des avec la question du leasing
social
et du des véhicules intermédiaires donc
excusez-moi donc la question la
cinquième question c'est sur le poids
toujours c'est une loi de physique je
l'ai dit
= MC2 il y a des scooters électriques
qui se développent à trois roues à 4
roues des vélos mobiles qui mixent
énergie musculaire électricité ou des
micro véhicules électriques extrêmement
bizarre
nommé véhicules intermédiaire par le
chercheur Frédéric
errant aucun des grands constructeurs ne
s'en vouloir aller en ce sens tant le
modèle économique du Sud
lourd par essence et profitable on sera
une question pour les constructeurs je
suis pas sûr qu'ils veulent répondre et
je termine sur le leasing social
le leasing social s'il est mis en oeuvre
de façon à permettre à de nombreux mais
c'est le ménages modestes et d'abord
dans les zones peu denses
je termine là pour changer de
motorisation entraînera une très forte
hausse de la demande comment
l'anticipez-vous comment travaillez-vous
avec le gouvernement sur le sujet Quel
type de véhicule comptez-vous développer
pour y répondre parce qu'il est évident
qu'il ne sera pas possible de faire
acheter des suivis électriques à 100
euros par mois excusez-moi je vous
remercie si j'ai des paroles à Philippe
Tabarro
oui merci président moi j'aurai une
question pour l'ensemble des
intervenants et une question plus
spécifique ou une remarque plus
spécifique pour Monsieur David
comme la rappeler le Président nous
sommes nous sommes dotés d'ambitieux
d'objectifs ambitieux de développement
des véhicules électriques
un défi pour votre filière vos filières
qui suppose de se réinventer de
développer de nouveaux
approvisionnements de nouveaux réseaux
de distribution
nous avons fixé enfin l'Europe et notre
pays ont fixé des objectifs dans un
contexte qui était un petit peu
différent c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire du contexte actuel vous l'avez
évoqué dans vos dans vos propos
introductifs mais nous devons faire face
à d'importantes du coup de l'électricité
des crânes de pénurie également comme
vous le savez de fortes tensions avec
certains matériaux et notamment au semi
conducteur donc dans ce contexte les
objectifs et c'est une vraie question il
faut peut-être se mouiller dans la
réponse est-ce que les objectifs de fin
de vente des véhicules thermiques vous
sentent toujours pouvoir être atteint
objectivement et d'après vous faut-il
faire ou non évoluer cette trajectoire
et donc la question ou la remarque
concernant les aides à l'acquisition des
véhicules électriques le président lonjo
la rappeler l'an dernier à l'occasion de
climat résilience nous nous étions
battus et je pèse mes mots pour
conserver dans le texte la création d'un
prêt à taux zéro pour l'achat des
véhicules propres alors après vous
l'avez rappelé Monsieur David deux ans
ce qui nous paraissait déjà insuffisant
au moment du des discussions à CMP avec
un plafond de ressources qui nous paraît
pas adapté mais enfin le gouvernement
s'est amusant c'était opposé à cette
proposition de même que la majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale et nous avons eu
gain de cause
alors on est satisfait aujourd'hui axe
puisse rentrer dans la loi et puis de
voir que certains députés souhaite
maintenant étendre le chant de ce prêt à
taux zéro avec le soutien du
gouvernement donc écoutez on peut que se
réjouir de ce vol de face et les temps
changent c'est plutôt amusant et pour
aller dans la terminer avec la question
sur le leasing social
de notre collègue jacquard j'aimerais
savoir si vous en savez plus ce que nous
sincèrement parce que depuis l'annonce
du gouvernement personne n'est en
capacité de nous dire comment le
dispositif va fonctionner qui sera
concerné et est-ce que cette mesure
répondra aux besoins croissants de nos
compatriotes en matière de véhicules
électriques et de pouvoir d'achat
merci chers collègues je vais donner la
parole à Monsieur David et puis après au
constructeur pour répondre aux questions
et puis s'il y a des compléments vous
les apporterez merci merci monsieur le
Président merci pour vos questions je
suis juste sur le règlement européen
effectivement le règlement européen
prévoit dans tel qu'il est discuté à
l'heure actuelle et une fin d'une vente
des véhicules thermiques en 2035 ça peut
être des véhicules électriques ça peut
être des véhicules à hydrogène les
véhicules à hydrogène sont une
possibilité pour avoir des véhicules
zéro émission dans le règlement européen
la France s'est battue au conseil pour
avoir une clause de revoyure
dans le dans la façon de déconstruire
les règlements à l'heure actuelle on
regarde
les les émissions à l'échappement mais
il nous semble dans la position
française que des carburants
qui pourrait prendre différentes formes
notamment des biocarburants ou des
carburants verts dans lequel on est à
zéro émission sur le cycle de vie du
carburant devrait aussi être considéré
et la France a obtenu au Conseil
une clause de revoyure de ce règlement
en 2026 dans lequel la Commission devra
faire des propositions pour pouvoir
élargir
élargir les véhicules qui pourraient
être utilisés après 2035 ça fera l'objet
de négociation européenne sur la tasse
force automobile effectivement on a une
tasse force un groupe qui réunit à la
fois les constructeurs automobiles les
équipements entiers l'ensemble de la
filière
automobile
réunies au sein de mobiliance et l'État
qui se réunit régulièrement qui est
animé par la plateforme automobile avec
un contrat stratégique de filière qui
arrive qui couvrait jusqu'à fin 2022 il
y a des réflexions actuelle pour avoir
un nouveau contrat stratégique de
filière de la filière automobile mais
c'est bien des échanges qui sont en
cours sur le leasing social
effectivement c'est un sujet compliqué
qui fait l'objet de très nombreuses très
nombreux travaux à l'heure actuelle au
sein de l'État mais aussi avec
l'ensemble des parties prenantes
notamment les constructeurs automobiles
et également les loueurs l'objectif
c'est bien que les Français modestes
puissent avoir accès pour moins de 100
euros par mois à un véhicule électrique
le donc le dispositif est en cours de en
cours de calage avec un gros point
d'attention du côté de l'État qui est
que les véhicules
qui soient qui font l'objet qui sont
utilisés dans le cadre de ligne social
soit des véhicules fabriqués en France
c'est-à-dire que ce qu'on ne souhaite
pas c'est que ce leasing social soit
fait avec des véhicules importer de
Chine et qu'en fait celui social soit la
porte ou pas la pour
accélérer l'importation du véhicules
électriques venant de Chine et donc les
discussions qui sont en cours sont
on pour objectif de voir comment on peut
maximiser et idéalement avoir 100% de
véhicules français dans le cadre du
leasing social
qui veut répondre
la question qui a été posée sur la fin
de la motorisation thermique et du
diesel
notre Président c'est longtemps prononcé
et positionné en demandant à ce que le
choix des technologies ne soit pas
imposé au constructeurs
cependant aujourd'hui la réglementation
européenne nous place dans une
trajectoire 100% électrique et nous
serons au rendez-vous et compliante de
cette réglementation
avec une technologie comme l'hybride
rechargeable évoquée préalablement nous
aidons à faire cette transition puisque
nous cumulons l'usage du véhicule 100%
électrique et nous accompagnons nos
clients dans cet usage urbain de
mobilité courte et néanmoins avec le
avec le la motorisation thermique nous
pouvons permettre à nos clients d'avoir
des trajets plus longs quand cela est
nécessaire
enfin pour la problématique de de
recherche alternative et de solutions
alternatives nous continuons d'innover
d'explorer puisque nous l'avons évoqué
nous avons des véhicules électriques qui
que nous équipons de pile à combustible
pour faire des véhicules hydrogène léger
et accompagner nos clients sur cette
problématique avec un refuge qui se fait
beaucoup plus rapidement une recharge
beaucoup plus rapide que la recharge
électrique et puis également pour
évoquer les problématiques très urbaines
nous n'étions pas de côté puisque nous
avons pour notre marque Citroën un petit
véhicule urbain qui s'appelle ami qui
rencontre un véritable succès et puis
pour une autre marque comme Peugeot nous
avons des vélos électriques nous avons
des scooters électriques et nous
considérons que le besoin vient du
client et que l'objet doit répondre à
ses problématiques donc nous ne sont pas
de côté ces mobilité légère
voilà pour ma part
oui monsieur le Président merci beaucoup
pour ces questions sur 2035
de ce qui a été voté monsieur Jacquin
vous avez soulevé un point sur
l'autonomie l'autonomie ça peut être
abordé plusieurs façons vous pouvez
empiler effectivement des batteries avec
eux en plus lourd mais on peut aussi
développer la charge rapide il y a deux
façons de voir les choses effectivement
tout le travail qu'on fait c'est pour
améliorer la charge rapide parce que
quand vous avez un véhicule la nouvelle
Mégane qui sera peut avoir jusqu'à 470
km d'autonomie si vous pouvez le
recharger rapidement ça couvre quand
même beaucoup des usages voilà donc il y
a tout ce travail là qui est que qu'on
essaie de faire pour essayer
effectivement de parce qu'il est pas
très coûtent cher évidemment donc
construit pour l'usager
le poids comme vous l'avez signalé
le poids comme vous l'avez signalé un
enjeu majeur assez un enjeu qui est bien
sûr en tant constructeur automobile on
prend systématiquement en compte dans
nos développements de véhicules le poids
ça impacte majeur sur la consommation
d'un véhicule thermique et ça n'a pas
que majeur sur l'autonomie d'un vécu
électrique l'autonomie c'est bien sûr le
premier critère que regarde les les
consommateurs qui veulent acheter un
véhicule électrique
le l'augmentation du poids des véhicules
c'est lié à plein de choses c'est aussi
lié à des dispositifs de dépollution aux
normes à la sécurité routière aux
adasses à beaucoup de choses donc c'est
un sujet qui est assez compliqué
comme comme ma collègue de scientist l'a
dit on développe aussi des petits
véhicules à Renault a été assez novateur
avec le Twizy il a rencontré le succès
qu'il a eu mais c'est un véhicule enfin
on a été assez novateur aussi sur sur
ces véhicules là et je peux vous dire
qu'on en fera d'autres aussi
on en fera d'autres donc c'est pas du
tout un segment qu'on abandonne je
signale aussi chrono à une twingo
électrique qui est quand même petit
véhicule
et qu'on va développer une R5 qui est
aussi un véhicule qui sera qui sera
abordable
vous avez abordé le transport des
marchandises je vais vous dire que dans
un groupe comme Renault c'est
extrêmement regardé en interne dans
notre Supply Chain c'est un véritable
sujet qu'on prend en compte pour
décarboner nos moyens de production et
donc je peux vous dire que par exemple
Renault depuis 2015 à 10 minutes 15% ses
émissions de CO2 liées son transport de
marchandises de ses transports de
véhicules au sein de au sein du groupe
et on veut faire -30% d'ici 2030
voilà je pense avoir
répondu une partie merci merci quelques
quelques compléments pour rappeler
également sur la partie autonomie ne pas
oublier qu'en moyenne les Français font
30 km par jour donc effectivement il
faut aussi prévoir des déplacements de
de plus longue distance que ce soit pour
des personnes qui en ont ce besoin ou
pour des besoins plus ponctuels on parle
et on pense souvent au départ en
vacances mais aujourd'hui on est à 60%
des modèles qui ont une autonomie de
plus de 300 km comme on l'a dit avec de
la recharge rapide qui est en train de
d'être déployée sur les grands axes
routiers on aura de quoi faire des
déposes et qui correspondront aussi aux
pauses recommandées par la sécurité
routière toutes les deux heures pour
faire une partie de son plein et pour
suivre son trajet un autre point sur le
le transport routier effectivement c'est
un sujet majeur en Europe 2% des
véhicules sont des sons sont les camions
et représentent pourtant 22% des
émissions de CO2 il y a une tassworce
qui s'est réunie à de nombreuses
reprises les deux dernières années
aujourd'hui on a une feuille de route de
décarbonation qui est prévue par Article
301 de la loi climat et résilience
qui a débuté ses travaux cet été avec
plusieurs groupes de travail sur les
différents scènements de mobilité
transforme marchandises transport de
voyageurs utilitaire léger les engins et
également un groupe de travail sur les
énergies justement pour réussir à
identifier la disponibilité de chaque
énergie et les les travaux à mettre en
oeuvre pour s'assurer que on puisse bien
répondre aux enjeux de la mobilité
lourde c'est notamment un travail qu'on
a pu faire pour identifier je vous
donner des chiffres tout à l'heure les
besoins à horizon 2025 et au-delà pour
ces pour ces segments là un dernier
point peut-être sur la question des
minerais c'est un point qui est
évidemment essentiel et qui doit être
adressé on a eu un rapport Varin qui est
extrêmement instructif je vous invite
également à consulter un exemplaire du
de géocion je crois du BRGM qui traite
de ces questions qui a été publiée avant
l'été il a important aujourd'hui qu'on
ne passe pas d'une d'une dépendance à
une autre et c'est pour ça je pense que
les constructeurs notamment se
présentent aujourd'hui développe aussi
des solutions sur le territoire français
pour s'assurer que le traitement des
minerais quand on ne dispose pas
forcément en Europe même si il y a quand
même des des filons qui pourraient être
si on le souhaitait traiter sur le
territoire européen mais pour que le
traitement ne se fasse plus à l'étranger
mais puisse se faire également en France
et le plus qu'on puisse capter une
partie importante de la valeur ce sera
important aussi là dessus c'est de bien
s'assurer de développer le recyclage
aujourd'hui il y a peu de peu de
batterie à recycler tout simplement
parce que on a eu peu de véhicules
en circulation on a une durée de vie de
10 à 15 ans pour ses batteries on l'a
dit en seconde vie pour du stockage on
peut aller encore sur 10 à 15 ans
supplémentaires et donc c'est des
batteries qui ne vont pas arriver tout
de suite au recyclage mais ce recyclage
va peut être aussi de réutiliser ces
minerais et de s'assurer qu'on est le
bon approvisionnement je vous remercie
si je vais passer une autre série de
questions je vais donner la parole à et
rigole
merci à Monsieur le Président ma
question s'adresse certainement plutôt à
Monsieur David
la loi de natation donc des mobilités
prévoient la possibilité pour les
collectivités locales et les
intercommunalités de réaliser des
schémas directeurs de développement des
stations de recharge pour véhicules
électriques ouverte au public en lien
avec les acteurs de la mobilité du
territoire ce dispositif leur donne un
rôle de chef d'orchestre du
développement de l'offre de la recharge
afin d'aboutir à une offre coordonnée
entre les maîtres d'ouvrage public et
privés
offre cohérente avec les politiques
locales des mobilité et adaptées aux
besoins alors moi je voudrais savoir si
ces schémas ont été adoptés par une
majorité de collectivités et s'il
permettrait réellement à déploiement
homogène sur le territoire des
infrastructures de recharge et puis
autre difficulté qui concernent
particulièrement les secteurs
sauvegardés ou protégés
avec la nécessité la nécessité technique
des équipements et les exigences
architecturales qui ne sont toujours pas
toujours compatibles et notamment au
niveau de l'implantation des bornes en
effet la placement d'une borne est
stratégique et conditionne l'intérêt de
son installation il est difficilement
envisageable de cacher une borne pour
respecter les prescriptions
architecturales et risquer que celle-ci
ne soit pas identifiable donc par
conséquent peut utiliser ensuite l'usage
d'une infrastructure de recharge est en
relativement nouveau ça nécessite aussi
une signalétique renforcée pour
expliquer au public son fonctionnement
notamment des panneaux des marquages au
sol et la signalétique est aussi
régulièrement remise en cause dans les
périmètres architecturaux donc
autre difficulté c'est qu'au niveau
administratif la déclaration préalable
pour un tel équipement apparaît comme
une contrainte non négligeable en effet
au vu des objectifs nationaux ça
pourrait représenter des milliers de
déclarations préalables qui seront
nécessaires on n'est-il pas nécessité de
faciliter les démarches d'installation
des infrastructures de recharge si on
veut répondre à un maillage cohérent sur
l'ensemble du territoire
merci la parole est à Jean-Michel
Houlgate
merci monsieur le Président j'ai
participé le mois dernier à
l'inauguration du plus grand site
français de points de charge pour les
voitures électriques avec 500 bornes qui
ont été installés d'ailleurs par une
filiale de DF isilia sur le parking
salarié de la du centre nucléaire de
production d'électricité de Flamanville
dans la Manche on peut bien évidemment
que se féliciter du développement du
réseau de bornes de recharge mais
néanmoins afin d'équilibrer les appels
de puissance donc un système de
foisonnement mais en place si bien que
les propriétaires de véhicules n'ont
plus d'une certaine façon la main sur le
planning de recharge et je rebondis sur
les propos de Jean-Philippe bonnet et de
pierre de Firma c'est à dire que les
véhicules électriques avec les smart
grid notamment vont devenir des
réservoirs énergétiques en réinjectant
sur le réseau la charge résiduelle en
période de pointe pour recharger bien
évidemment on heureuse je comptais ce
pas du tout le bien fondé de de ce
système mais là on bascule dans un autre
monde à savoir et je prends pour exemple
l'arrêté minist qui fait beaucoup parler
de lui aujourd'hui du 22 septembre
dernier qui donne pouvoir au
gestionnaire de réseau public de
distribution d'électricité de désactiver
la charge des ballons d'eau chaude
pendant la période de 11h et 15h30 donc
le midi et cela sans concertation donc
le lissage risque de se faire de façon
arbitraire par le biais des technologies
numériques donc quel dispositif
d'informations d'associations ou
d'appropriation avez-vous prévu pour
accompagner donc ses propriétaires de
véhicules électriques qui vont
contribuer à ce lissage et donc
réinjecter sur le réseau le surplus de
charge lorsqu'il resteront lorsqu'ils
seront rentrés le soir à leur domicile
merci la parole de Joël Bigot
oui merci monsieur le Président merci
madame messieurs pour ces informations
extrêmement intéressantes il est vrai
que on assiste à un très fort
développement de du véhicule électrique
à l'heure actuelle et à l'heure de la
planification écologique je voudrais
savoir où est le rôle de l'État dans le
déploiement des bornes de recharge et de
manière équilibrée sur l'ensemble du
territoire c'est un vrai enjeu en région
Centre Val de Loire ou encore un pays de
Loire la région que je connais le mieux
ou cette dernière ne compte que 86
points de recharge pour 100000 habitants
ce qui est très en deçà de la moyenne
nationale comment assurez-vous une
répartition équilibrée du réseau sur
l'ensemble du territoire y a-t-il une
attention particulière portée au
territoire peu dense afin de garantir
l'égalité territoriale et un maillage
intelligent à l'heure actuelle quand on
prend son véhicule électrique pour faire
certaines distances c'est un véritable
stress on ne sait pas
les limites de
du voyage si je puis dire et puis je
voudrais également poser une question au
constructeur vous avez beaucoup parlé de
recyclage des batteries vous parlez de
l'économie circulaire je ne vous sauf à
que j'ai pas compris ou malentendu je ne
vous ai pas entendu parler de rétrofit
le rétrofit c'est le substitution d'une
motorisation à une autre je crois que
dans un contexte de pénurie de métaux
qui a annoncé déjà j'encovici c'est une
une initiative qui peut être
intéressante et je voudrais savoir si
c'est toujours d'actualité je vous
remercie merci la parole est à Guillaume
chevrolier
merci monsieur le Président merci aux
intervenants pour pour leur propos je
trouvais d'ailleurs que c'est des propos
qualifient une situation plutôt
satisfaisante du véhicule électrique
aujourd'hui tout en posant un certain
nombre de constats qu'on partage et qui
sont partagés par les Français notamment
le fait que le véhicule électrique est
un coût d'acquisition quand même élevé
malgré les dispositifs mis en place
alors est-ce que vous avez des
propositions pour pour améliorer
les ventes et permettre donc une baisse
des coûts de production des véhicules
électriques ou est-ce que puisqu'on
approche du débat budgétaire enfin on y
est sur les aides et ce qui sont
suffisantes ou est-ce que sont bien
ciblées est-ce que vous avez des
propositions c'est le moment dans dans
formuler parce qu'encore une fois on a
senti que au travers des différentes
interventions la situation elle était
plutôt satisfaisante
[Musique]
merci chers collègues je donne la parole
à Jacques fernit oui merci monsieur le
Président ma question s'adresse je pense
d'abord au constructeur
leur secteur industriel les
constructeurs les équipementsiers c'est
un secteur qui a déjà perdu beaucoup
d'emplois rien que dans mon Grand-Est
depuis 2007 c'est 40 % de ses emplois
qu'on disparu alors il semble établi que
la production de voitures électriques
est nettement moins intensive en emploi
que la production de véhicules
thermiques il y a eu l'an dernier un
rapport important de la CFDT de la
Fondation pour la Nature et l'Homme qui
a conclu que seule la transition
accélérée en France permettrait de
maintenir durablement les savoir-faire
les productions et donc les emplois ils
en appellent pour cela à un grand
dialogue social industriel sociétal pour
construire un scénario positif ce qui
ressemble un petit peu à la démarche de
nos voisins allemands en clair comme en
pensez-vous que nous pourrions à la fois
réussir cette transition de
l'électromobilité et éviter aussi les
trop lourds impacts sociaux en termes
d'emploi
merci la parole est un jeu de prévu
merci monsieur le Président merci à
toutes et tous pour vous interventions
très riches alors moi j'avais d'abord
une première question comme mes
collègues sur les bornes de recharge je
suis donc dans le Lot dans un
département très rural et nous avions le
Congrès des maires à Cahors vendredi
dernier plusieurs élus étaient venus
avec leur véhicule électrique et il n'y
avait pas de bornes de recharge au Parc
des Expositions donc ça a été pour eux
effectivement un gros stress et de
chercher éventuellement une prise
quelque part où il pourrait
se brancher parce que certains venaient
du nord du département et on est à
presque 100 km pour certains donc voilà
c'est pour reprendre les questions qu'on
formule et mes collègues comment assurer
un maillage correct et j'allais dire
équitable sur le territoire et pas
seulement pour les habitants des
territoires ruraux mais finalement parce
que vous avez dit que certes la avoir
des recherches se font exclusivement à
domicile mais tout un chacun et amener à
aller à partir en vacances et à se
retrouver à un moment ou un autre sur un
de ces territoires là et la mobilité ne
sera assurée que si l'on a partout de
quoi se recharger et ça il faut le
comprendre ça concerne pas que les
habitants des territoires ruraux mais
tout à chacun pour ses déplacements et
puis deuxième question parce que j'ai
appris ça du coup parce que j'ai échangé
avec les maires qui étaient venus avec
leur véhicule électrique et qui m'ont
confié ce que je ne savais pas et qui
n'a pas été évoqué c'est le coût très
variable de la recharge et certains
m'ont dit parfois sur certaines bornes
de recharge et bien cela nous coûte plus
cher qu'un plein avec de l'essence
classique donc je voulais vous demander
alors je ne sais pas qui pourra répondre
comment fait-on puisque on a on est
d'accord on passe au véhicule électrique
c'est pour diminuer les gaz à effet de
serre pour
pour qu'il y ait moins de pollution donc
ça c'est déjà évidemment très vertueux
mais par ailleurs comme le véhicule est
acheté beaucoup plus cher
ça va être difficile l'évolution si
circule partout que et c'est ce que j'ai
entendu et
qui a été constaté que le la recharge
peut être parfois elle est très
irrégulière au niveau des coûts et elle
peut être parfois assez cher voilà je
vous remercie
merci pour cette première série je vais
dans la parole à Didier mandeli et après
je vous proposais de répondre merci mais
merci monsieur le Président moi j'ai une
question plutôt sur l'amont et sur la
production et notamment précisément sur
l'origine des de l'énergie et je pense
aux énergies renouvelables
nous avons actuellement
un texte sur le développement des
énergies renouvelables la simplification
et l'accélération et la question que je
me pose c'est puisque dans la mesure où
88% vous l'avez dit des utilisateurs
sont en résidence individuelle
résidentiel particulier est-ce que même
si on l'a bien compris aussi les
recherches se font en grande partie la
nuit est-ce qu'on pourrait imaginer
alors c'est une suggestion en même temps
est-ce qu'on pourrait imaginer que dans
l'offre pour un véhicule électrique qui
est un espèce de package
auprès de l'acquéreur pour
quand on installe une borne électrique
imaginez la provenance de l'énergie et
elle est jusqu'à proposer avec des
opérateurs dont c'est le métier et les
constructeurs automobiles et des
installateurs une offre globale qui
permettrait l'autoconsommation c'est un
élément qu'on va intégrer dans le texte
je dévoile rien
en primeur mais l'autoconsommation est
un élément important et pourrait être
une réponse
sur les besoins du réseau demain
concernant l'acquisition de véhicules
électriques
merci je vous propose Monsieur David
peut-être de répondre et rigole et puis
à Guillaume chevrolier sur les questions
qui ont été posées
France avec qui on travaille beaucoup
sur ces sujets sur les schémas les
schémas directeurs
d'installation des des infrasions de
recharge de véhicules électriques c'est
effectivement une disposition qui est
dans lequel un grand nombre de
collectivités se sont saisis de cette
possibilité
la majorité des schémas sont faits au
niveau départemental notamment avec un
appui très fort des ade des autoritaires
réalisatrices de la distribution
d'électricité
donc c'est bien beaucoup de schémas qui
sont en cours peu sont approuvés on a 6
à l'heure actuelle qui sont validées
mais on estime que d'ici la fin de
l'année plus de la moitié
seront approuvés
euh c'est c'est vraiment un travail qui
qui a qui dans lequel les collectifs
sont vraiment saisi de cet outil c'est
aussi un outil qui permet de voir de
planifier au niveau local
les bornes
et notamment de s'assurer que sur un
territoire on est un maillage suffisant
de bornes dans les mailles dans les la
planification qui est réfléchie au
niveau de l'État
elle est d'une part sur le réseau
routier national c'est là où on a un
engagement de l'État d'avoir sur ce
réseau routier national un maillage
extrêmement étroit
de bornes de recharge rapide ça concerne
les autoroutes mais ça concerne aussi
les les voies rapides non concédés
et ensuite au niveau local on a un
dispositif d'aide
qui finance à l'heure actuelle 30% de la
borne je pense que à un moment on est en
fait dans une dynamique à la fois de
développement de véhicules électriques
et de développement des bornes
il est clair que il va falloir mettre en
place un système d'aide d'un repérer des
zones blanches et avoir un système
d'aide spécifique pour pouvoir couvrir
les zones blanches
si on en constate mais on voit quand
même que dans l'ensemble des territoires
et la verre pourra compléter on a un
développement très fort des bornes que
ce soit en milieu
urbain mais aussi en milieu rural
oui monsieur depuis
je me proposais de de compléter sur
certaines questions et notamment sur les
schémas directeur en effet irve puisque
le gestionnaire de réseau est un acteur
important de l'établissement de ces
schémas et nous accompagnons les schémas
directeurs qui sont en cours sur le
territoire on a du coup une visibilité
assez assez importante après d'une
centaine de ces schémas directeurs sont
en cours en effet seulement certains
sont validés mais
ce qui est intéressant dans cette
démarche c'est que elle permet de
partager
le les
scénarios de développement de la
mobilité électrique que nous avons de
façon nous sommes capables de décrire de
façon très locale avec les collectivités
locales en charge de ces schémas
directeur et circuit de d'intégrer aussi
tout ce qui est de l'initiative privé on
parlait tout à l'heure des plans de
déploiement par exemple sur les parkings
d'hypermarchés etc
ça aussi c'est une composante très
importante de du maillage que nous
enedis nous voyons aussi du fait de
cette vision un peu 360
que nous avons et donc ça nous pouvons
ensemble avec les collectivités locales
intégrer ces éléments là pour arriver à
un maillage le plus harmonieux possible
alors en effet il y a des zones de
France qui sont pas encore très
qui ont pas vraiment démarré mais dans
l'ensemble je trouve que le mouvement
est très bien parti et je voulais aussi
indiquer qu'il y a une incitation à
s'inscrire dans ces schémas directeurs
qui je pense est assez efficace pour
garantir justement l'harmonie c'est que
les coûts raccordement au réseau des
bornes de recharge qui sont installées
dans le de ces schémas directeurs sont
pris en charge à 75%. donc c'est un
dispositif aussi de soutien qui est
important pour accompagner ces schémas
directeurs je peux peut-être dire un mot
aussi sur la partie sur la question
je crois de Monsieur Leclerc sur le le
smart grid le pilotage etc pour dire que
effectivement c'est c'est une
caractéristique de l'usage mobilité
électrique très intéressante pour un
électricien
le fait qu'il soit pilotable comme le
ballon d'eau chaude c'est pas parce
qu'il est pilotable que c'est
nécessairement au réseau de distribution
d'en assurer le pilotage c'est plutôt
pas le cas c'est plutôt alors on a on a
cité l'arrêté récent là mais on est dans
des circonstances
à l'approche de cet hiver tout à fait
particulière mais autrement c'est pas
c'est pas au réseau de distribution de
de piloter et je dirais le 8 ou j
puisque c'est le c'est le terme consacré
pour évoquer le caractère
bilatéral de communication d'un d'un
véhicule électrique c'est dans un avenir
un petit peu plus loinain c'est la
capacité pour un véhicule de réinjecter
sur le réseau
une partie de la production qu'il a
stocké dans sa batterie bon certains
véhicules sont déjà compatibles il y a
des expérimentations qui se font ici et
là on n'est pas encore à
l'industrialisation de ce de ce procédé
merci pour compléter ce que vous venez
de dire j'ai
dans mon département on a installé avec
le syndicat d'énergie et en partenariat
effectivement avec vous en partenariat
avec la région de Franche-Comté à
l'époque
ce maillage territorial
et donc et pour le prix pour répondre à
Angèle effectivement c'est le syndicat
d'énergie donc
ce que tu disais tout à l'heure
effectivement si jamais on fait des prix
énormes
et que ça coûte beaucoup plus cher
encore que le que l'essence ou diesel
c'est important mais je pense que les
syndicats d'énergie ont un rôle
important à jouer dans les départements
pour l'installation de ce genre de
matériel le seul souci qu'on avait
c'était est-ce que c'est du matériel
est-ce que c'est du matériel rapide ou
pas c'était c'était la complication de
qu'on a eu
merci monsieur le Président juste une
précision
c'est toi que vous avez évoqué sur le
même plan la possibilité pour un
véhicule de réinjecter de l'électricité
dans le réseau et la possibilité de
déconnecter le signaler creuse sur les
sur les chauffe-eau cet hiver alors bien
sûr sont deux mécanismes qui permettent
d'agir sur la demande mais clairement on
est dans deux registres totalement
différents sur le premier mécanisme nous
sommes dans des mécanismes de en termes
technocratique thermocratique de
valorisation de la flexibilité
on se dit qu'il y a un gain collectif à
faire à pouvoir lisser les appels de
puissance et lorsqu'un véhicule est en
mesure de le faire l'idée c'est d'avoir
la possibilité pour un propriétaire de
véhicule d'offrir ce service et d'être
rémunéré pour cela il fait gagner de
l'argent à toute la collectivité et il
récupère une partie de cette valeur mais
il est évident que personne n'imagine
sérieusement de le faire sans l'accord
du propriétaire ce serait du plus
récemment du vol
donc ça c'est quelque chose qu'on veut
pouvoir développer comme un mécanisme
qui permet les propriétaires de tirer de
la valeur de la batterie qu'ils ont et
de la voiture qui est qui est au garage
si ils estiment que c'est possible
compatible avec leurs usage après sur la
question des Chauffours on est sur des
mesures d'urgence de sauvegarde liés à
une situation de crise énergétique et
si on le met en oeuvre c'est parce que
en estimera que si nécessaire pour
éviter de devoir couper totalement
l'électricité à sa grande usager donc on
met en balance cette restriction
temporaire d'un usage dont on estime
qu'elle est surmontable parce que le
chauffe-eau fonctionnera la nuit et que
voilà on prendra la douche le matin par
rapport et c'est bien pour éviter de
découpures que on le mettra en avalan on
est dans deux registres totalement
différents et même si ça agit sur la
demande c'est bien deux contextes
d'usage très différents
merci Monsieur Montluçon puis les
constructeurs
oui merci monsieur le Président je
voulais revenir notamment sur sur le
maillage alors évidemment on vous
rejoint sur la nécessité d'assurer un
maillage aussi homogène que possible et
notamment de répondre aux besoins des
habitants et des personnes qui
travaillent dans un territoire et
également des touristes et des personnes
qui qui s'y arrêteront pour autant
peut-être pour apporter un petit peu de
nuance deux points le premier ne pas
regarder que le nombre de points de
recharge mais également regarder la
puissance installée on parlait de de
Franche-Comté si on prend la Bourgogne
Franche-Comté à la 4 fois moins de
points de recharge que l'Île-de-France
qui est la première région de France en
nombre de points de recharge pour autant
puissance installée elle n'a que deux
fois moins de puissance ce qui
s'explique aussi parce que en
Île-de-France beaucoup de points de
recharge installés ont été des points de
recharge lents ou normaux pour répondre
aux besoins des personnes qui n'ont pas
de place de stationnement chez elle et
donc c'est le deuxième point de cette
nuance c'est que dans un certain nombre
de territoires on a une part de maison
individuelle plus importante et donc des
capacités de recharge chez soi plus
importantes nous on réunit depuis 10 ans
dans le cadre d'un cercle des
collectivités locales électromobile donc
une bonne partie des syndicats d'énergie
également des communes et métropoles
est-ce qu'elle nous disent aujourd'hui
notamment pour les territoires ruraux
c'est pas qu'elle souhaite forcément
déployées beaucoup plus de points de
recharge mais développer de la charge
rapide notamment à des endroits
stratégiques par exemple des lieux
touristiques où les personnes vont venir
et rester une heure deux heures ou une
après-midi et d'adapter la recharge en
ce sens et c'est là où on trouve tout
l'intérêt des schémas directeur et de
cette vision très locale du déploiement
de la recharge qui doit s'apprécier au
vu de type d'habitation et de des flux
qui sont qui sont mis en place sur ce
sujet spécifique du Palais des Congrès
et bien je pense que d'ici 2025 vos élus
trouveront une solution car ce qui est
prévu dans la loi
d'orientation des mobilités
non résidentiels à 2025 alors c'est
c'est toujours c'est toujours trop tard
surtout quand on cherche une une place
pour pour brancher son véhicule mais il
y a déjà des éléments qui seront qui
seront mis en place et les centres
commerciaux notamment ont prévu des
déploiements importants
aux besoins et aux territoires sur les
schémas directeur une problématique que
tous nous font remonter c'est la
difficulté à intégrer les opérateurs
privés et par opérateur privé j'entends
plus spécifiquement des acteurs comme
les centres commerciaux comme des des
supermarchés qui vont avoir des
déploiements importants et évidemment si
on si un centre commercial déploie des
bornes il n'y a pas beaucoup d'intérêt
pour la puissance publique locale dans
déployer juste à côté mais il y a une
vraie difficulté à organiser ce dialogue
et et en la matière si je pense que que
tous les syndicats d'énergie seraient
ravis de pouvoir avancer sur le sujet un
point sur l'emploi effectivement on a
en partie à ces travaux de la FNH et la
CFDT qui sont extrêmement intéressants
avoir également en tête qu'on va avoir
des besoins extrêmement importants en
installateur de bandes de recharge il y
a aussi avoir d'autres métiers au-delà
du secteur automobile qui vont être
nécessaires pour le développement de la
mobilité électrique et des travaux
devraient être engagés le plus tôt
possible pour assurer les reconversions
et leurs un premier temps les formations
dernier point pardon sur le coup alors
effectivement beaucoup de de
cartes sont un peu remanie à l'heure
actuelle entre l'inflation et les
problématiques d'approvisionnement mais
dans une situation
normale ce qu'on estimait c'est
qu'autour de 2027 on aurait une équité
prix entre les véhicules électriques et
les véhicules thermiques et surtout
l'intérêt aujourd'hui qui est déjà
validé notamment par par des études de
l'USA Que Choisir c'est qu'on a une un
véhicule qui est déjà plus rentable des
trois quatre ans de possession grâce au
de l'énergie et justement cette recharge
aujourd'hui notamment la recharge
publique on a des opérateurs dont les
coûts de fournitures ont été triplés
alors les situations sont très diverses
certains ont des contrats qui
n'arriveront à échéance que l'an
prochain d'autres y sont confrontés dès
à présent mais on anticipe une
augmentation de certains sur certains
réseaux de 20 à 50% liés à cette crise
conjoncturelle alors ça ne remet pas en
cause évidemment la mobilité électrique
dans sur le long terme et ça ne remet
pas non plus en cause le le cette
rentabilité de la mobilité électrique
quand on a du 2 euros 100 km de recharge
à domicile on a du 12 euros 100 km pour
pour du thermique donc l'écart est
encore extrêmement grand et pour autant
vous invitons peut-être à réfléchir
également à un accompagnement des
opérateurs notamment des opérateurs de
bord de recharge public et également en
copropriété
la situation des opérateurs est
particulière car il bénéficie pas
exactement des mêmes conditions que que
les particuliers peuvent avoir
aujourd'hui sur le bouclier tarifaire je
vous remercie merci je vais donner la
parole aux constructeurs
on va essayer de faire vite parce que
j'ai encore 7 demandes de parole alors
merci je vais essayer de faire très vite
du coup je vais peut-être deux sujets
qui ont été évoqués le premier le
rétrofit
alors ça me permet de expliquer très
rapidement ce qu'on fait à l'usine de
Flins qui est donc une usine qui
fonctionne c'est pas un projet l'usine
fonctionne c'est une usine qui va être
entièrement dédiée à prolonger la durée
de vie des véhicules et de leurs
composants donc il y a un certain nombre
de projets qui sont dedans comme j'ai
dit la réparation des batteries lors des
mentalement des activités de seconde vie
etc travailler en boucle courte sur les
matériaux et dans le cadre de ces
activités on a effectivement le projet
de faire du retrofit de véhicule alors
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que il est
compliqué d'être rentable sur du
retrofit de véhicules particuliers
anciens etc parce que ça coûtait ça
coûte extrêmement faire c'est des
véhicules qui ont pas être fortement été
conçus à l'origine pour ça qui par
ailleurs continue à s'abîmer enfin ils
ont une vie voilà donc on cible un
certain nombre de véhicules par exemple
des véhicules utilitaires et notamment
des véhicules utilitaires transformés un
artisan par exemple qui a un camion
frigorifique c'est un aménagement qui
est très cher il peut avoir maintenant
des difficultés à rentrer dans une des
feux ça c'est typiquement le genre de
service qu'on voudrait développer en
premier pour pousser cette logique de
rétrofit l'aider à effectivement changer
réaménager son camion donc c'est des
c'est logique comme ça qu'on développe
encore une fois sur le véhicule
particulier ça reste compliqué de
trouver une rentabilité mais c'est pas
du tout un sujet que que qu'on a oublié
en tout cas on y travaille fortement
sur l'emploi
effectivement alors en règle générale de
toute façon produire un moteur
électrique ça n'a rien à voir avec que
produire un moteur thermique donc c'est
des compétences totalement différentes
donc on a un énorme enjeu de reformation
de nos salariés et au-delà de nos
partenaires etc donc Renault on a lancé
pardon pour le jeu de mots qui a
dispositif s'appelle Renault University
qui vise à justement reformer nos
salariés on prévoit de faire 10000
reformations changements de compétences
etc
d'ici à 2024 il y en a déjà 2600 qui ont
été réalisés avec des campus sur nos
usines dont un flan puisque c'est une
transformation complète de l'usine à
Cléon ou en origine de moteur où on
apprend aux gens à changer en fait le le
métier qu'ils avaient et un des sujets
majeurs pour recréer de l'emploi c'est
de ne pas en rester la logique
d'assembler des véhicules en France mais
de localiser la valeur ajoutée en France
donc un véhicule électrique vous avez
beaucoup d'opportunités de création de
nouvelles filières sur l'électronique de
puissance sur les batteries c'est
vraiment de la haute technologie c'est
des métiers de pointe et c'est tout ce
qu'on veut essayer de développer autour
de nos usines avec tous les différents
projets que que je vous avais
listé dans mon dans mon dans mon
introduction donc c'est vraiment l'enjeu
c'est d'arriver à localiser la valeur
ajoutée du véhicule électrique en France
pour recréer de l'emploi au-delà de ce
qu'on connaît habituellement c'est à
dire reproduire des moteurs
merci
OK
permettrait de compléter un petit peu
sur l'action que l'on peut avoir pour
nos clients sur le coup on travaille je
vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure sur les
offres avec des offres innovantes sur
des véhicules comme i208 ou corsaï des
petits véhicules afin de diminuer nos
offres commerciales pour aider
accompagner nos clients à entrer dans
cet univers et puis également au niveau
du produit par exemple avec la 500
électrique où on a une offre de petites
batteries qui permet à des clients qui
n'ont pas le besoin d'avoir un véhicule
lourd avec plus d'autonomie de choisir
cette option de petites batteries donc
vraiment toujours laisser le choix à nos
clients et en terme de les accompagner
également pour les problématiques de
coût de recharge vous évoquez les prix
très cher effectivement sur des
situations de recherche exceptionnelle
comme les comme les autres situations
autoroutières mais c'est des choses qui
existaient déjà avec le thermique un
plein sur autoroute était déjà un peu
plus coûteux voilà donc on essaie
d'accompagner nos clients pour qu'ils
aient une solution de recharge et on a
une JV qui s'appelle il solution movie
solution pour pouvoir donner un accès à
l'ensemble des bornes de recharge et que
le client puisse choisir une recharge
peu coûteuse
s'il n'est pas pressé ou coûteuse en
fonction de l'urgence de son déplacement
voilà mais effectivement on essaie
d'accompagner nos clients avec des
offres multiples et puis le dernier le
dernier sujet sur le l'énergie
renouvelable
monsieur Longeon je crois que pas de
bêtises on a 23 hectares de
photosvoltaïque à Sochaux qui nous
permet
d'alimenter 10% des besoins de
l'agglomération donc le groupe est
vraiment engagé dans ces problématiques
vertes voilà
merci je vais donner la parole à
Monsieur gilet
merci monsieur le Président pour revenir
sur le la problématique des poids des
véhicules
aujourd'hui au niveau des constructeurs
si on fait court vous produisez moins de
véhicules et vous gagnez plus d'argent
et ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
les véhicules sont montés en gamme et la
plus-value que vous dégagez sur ces
montées en gamme de véhicule elle est
effectivement plus importante donc il y
a une réelle inquiétude aujourd'hui sur
la production d'entrée de gamme et on a
vu sur les véhicules thermiques
d'ailleurs des abandons de certains
petits véhicules urbains et qui
interroge aujourd'hui quant au
développement effectivement de la
filière donc est-ce que vous pouvez
vraiment nous rassurer sur ce sujet là
sur le développement de petits véhicules
électriques urbain et à ce titre est-ce
qu'il y a également des possibilités de
développement de petits véhicules
urbains qui n'est pas besoin de permis
de conduire comme il existe aujourd'hui
des voiturettes qui sont très utiles
pour beaucoup de catégories de la
population concernant la planification
j'ai bien entendu la question des
schémas directeurs mais au niveau aussi
de RTE des grand réseau électrique
comment cette planification aujourd'hui
est-elle inscrite et du moins est-elle
inscrite dans les schémas aujourd'hui
directeurs régionaux les stradettes
voire même comment cristallise au niveau
des scottes des schémas de cohérence
d'organisation territoriaux qui sont là
pour accueillir les nouvelles
populations ce qui veut dire derrière
une politique de ressources et de
besoins aussi en terme d'énergie donc
est-ce qu'il y a une réflexion en termes
de planification territoriale qui soit
vraiment partagé par les collectivités
en termes de planification au bout du
bout en termes de demande électrique ça
induit aussi des questions sur le
renforcement des réseaux à charge des
collectivités et donc est-ce qu'il y a
également une vision particulière qui
est partagée sur le renforcement des
réseaux qui sera en charge des
collectivités sur la montée en puissance
sur la pros territoriale on parle
également de stockage tampon est-ce que
vous pourriez évoquer ce sujet pour
qu'on ait une vision un petit peu plus
précise enfin concernant les les bornes
beaucoup de mes collègues ont abordé ce
sujet jusque là je voudrais aborder sur
un autre angle de la portabilité
financière donc je vais m'adresser
plutôt à Harvard par rapport à ça au
sens où il y a différentes catégories de
bornes et d'abonnement et aujourd'hui on
a un vrai problème de portabilité
financière c'est à dire de passer d'un
abonnement à un autre ou alors on a un
tarif qui n'est pas un tarif très
intéressant puisqu'on bénéficie pas d'un
abonnement partagé et ça c'est une
question de fond parce qu'il y a une
multiplicité aujourd'hui de fournisseurs
et donc on n'a pas une portabilité comme
je l'appelle mais au niveau financière
est-ce que vous pourriez m'éclairer sur
le sujet je vous remercie
la parole est à Martin de Sidrac
merci président merci à nos intervenants
de ce matin et en tant que sénatrice des
Yvelines mes questions vont
essentiellement être orientées
évidemment vers les deux producteurs
présents donc et Renault mais également
aussi au représentants du ministère
Monsieur David donc on sait aujourd'hui
que le marché de la voiture électrique
est environ autour de 16%,
ça semble relativement bas mais on sait
que avec le basculement tout électrique
en 2035 en Europe on s'attend en réalité
un déploiement un développement
exponentiel de la voiture électrique
cela étant dit il y a un aspect qu'on
n'a pas encore abordé ce matin c'est
celui des déchets ça a été dit plus ou
moins monsieur Chang a évoqué l'usine de
Flins dans les Yvelines effectivement
toutefois moi j'avais une autre une
question qui porte sur nos territoires
ultramarins nos territoires ultramarins
aujourd'hui on le voit aussi puisque ce
sont des rues donc des régions
ultra périphériques de l'Union
européenne sont soumises ont même
contraintes que nous or aujourd'hui la
voiture électrique effectivement
s'impose de plus en plus et le sujet de
l'exportation du déchet le sujet de la
recyclabilité du traitement du déchet je
ne vais pas développer l'arête véhicule
je
pensais déjà à la batterie ne sont pas
réellement prises en charge localement
or j'entends bien le discours
environnemental que nous tenons ce matin
et c'est normal nous sommes dans la
commission aménagement du territoire et
développement durable
il y a évidemment la masse critique des
d'unités que l'on peut avoir dans nos
territoires
ultramarins mais si je prends l'exemple
de la Réunion on voit l'impact
environnemental réel qu'il peut y avoir
sur le volet de la voiture électrique
dans ces territoires là donc première
question vis-à-vis de stellantiste et de
et de Renaud parce que dans vos
réflexions il y a des réflexions qui
portent sur nos territoires ultramarins
et Monsieur David quelle est la
stratégie aujourd'hui du gouvernement
autant dans l'Hexagone la métropole
voilà de beaucoup de questions étaient
posées par mes collègues je ne vais pas
revenir là-dessus mais vis-à-vis de ces
territoires ultramarins qu'en est-il en
fait comment est-ce qu'on va arriver à
avoir à imposer la voiture électrique
avec toute la vertu que qu'on lui donne
et qu'on lui prête aujourd'hui dans le
territoire européen c'est à dire
continental je vous remercie
merci la parole est à Cyril pelva
merci monsieur le président
il faut reconnaître que la montée en
puissance de la part des véhicules
électriques dans le parc automobile aura
forcément un impact positif mais aussi
négatif qui nous faudra anticiper pour
ma part je souhaite alerter sur les
risques qui pèsent sur notre tissu
industriel et en particulier celui du
décolletage dont la majorité des
entreprises sont situées dans la vallée
de l'arbre dans mon département de la
Haute-Savoie selon une étude sollicité
par la plateforme automobile est
réalisée par le cabinet AX partner les
industries de l'automobile perdront
d'ici quelques années 15 à 30% de leur
effectif de production cela représente
donc jusqu'à 90 000 emplois
potentiellement menacés selon le
scénario le plus pessimiste tandis que
la transition vers l'électrique
présentera de permettra de créer entre
8000 et 11000 emplois à condition de
former les salariés et de faire monter
en compétences
on est bien loin de parvenir à compenser
les pertes d'emploi qui se profile la
plateforme automobile s'inquiète en
particulier pour certaines filières dont
le décolletage l’emboutissage la
fonderie qui sont des métiers qui
dépendent fortement du marché automobile
les voitures électriques nécessitent 8
fois moins de pièces de décolleté que
dans une véhicule dans une voiture
thermique et la contribution des
fournisseurs français à la fabrication
d'éléments et de pièces de motorisation
risque de diminuer de plus de 10% avec
un risque de délocaliser les productions
dans des pays au coût plus compétitifs
un plan diversification à destination du
secteur des décolletage a été mis en
place l'année dernière par ministère de
l'économie il est bien évidemment
bienvenue mais il nous faudra rester
vigilant et poursuivre l'accompagnement
de la filière j'insiste également sur la
nécessité d'accroître notre
accompagnement en matière de recherche
et développement des entreprises du
secteur qui sera un maillon essentiel de
leur diversification plus spécifiquement
je souhaiterais savoir si la DGC inclut
ses considération dans ces travaux en
matière de développement d'électrique et
si elle travaille de concert avec le
ministère de l'Économie à ce sujet merci
la parole est à Nicole Bonnefoy
oui merci monsieur le président
de première
remarque sera pour le porte-parole
denedis qui dans son propos liminaire a
dit que le raccordement réseau des
producteurs d'énergie renouvelables
étaient une priorité et donc de ce point
de vue je voudrais évoquer avec lui les
problèmes que nous avons justement dans
raccordement au réseau dans mon
département qui est celui de la Charente
ou de nombreux chantiers de panneaux
photovoltaïques sont à l'arrêt et la
faute
a des transformateurs déclarés saturés
par enedis j'ai encore reçu ce matin un
courrier d'un porteur de projet sur donc
une centrale photovoltaïque qui
demandait à enedis le la durée de pour
le raccordement réseau le délai était de
7 à 10 ans c'est à peu près la même
chose sur nombre de projets ce qui bien
évidemment pose de nombreuses
difficultés rappelant par ailleurs que
les projets s'inscrivent au au fur et à
mesure de leur arrivée et que c'est en
priorité les projets éoliens qui sont
inscrits et donc les petits projets
photovoltaïques en particulier alors
qu'il nécessite moins de temps pour leur
réalisation qu'un projet éolien de ont
des délais incroyables de 7 ans 10 ans
etc donc il y a un vrai vrai problème et
une vraie colère sur les territoires
quant à ceux qui produisent des énergies
renouvelables et qui n'ont pas de
capacité de pouvoir se raccorder au
réseau dans des délaiss corrects donc de
mon point de vue il y a là un manque
d'anticipation certains donc quelque
chose à améliorer ensuite mes questions
s'adresseront au constructeurs première
question c'est que pensez-vous de la vie
tranchée de Jean-Marc jeancovici a déjà
été dit qui estime que nos ressources en
métaux Cobaltium nickel ne permettront
pas de convertir l'ensemble du parc
automobile une deuxième question c'est
au regard de notre dépendance aux métaux
rares la filière automobile française
tels les moyens de lutter contre la
concurrence chinoise et la dernière
question c'est est-ce que les
constructeurs s'attaquent aujourd'hui à
la lutte contre l'émission de
micro-articules
issues de l'usure des pneus une étude
récente démonte en effet que les pneus
émettent 1850 fois plus de particules
que l'échappement et nous l'avions
d'ailleurs largement évoqué dans le
rapport remis ici au Sénat par moi-même
et mon collègue Rémi Pointreau merci
pour vos réponses
merci je vais donner la parole à Madame
filleul
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
messieurs madame j'ai mené avec ma
collègue synergog un travail sur la
question de la logistique urbaine pour
la commission du développement durable
je travaille était justifié par
l'augmentation du nombre de ZFE et
également par le développement du
e-commerce nous avons à cette occasion
rencontré nombre de partenaires de
professionnels d'associations de toute
nature qui nous ont signalés leur
impossibilité à court et à moyen terme
de se procurer des véhicules propres non
pas les véhicules
légers mais les véhicules plus lourds
j'ai compris j'ai cru comprendre en tout
cas monsieur Leclerc que vous disiez qui
avait à ce propos des tasses que force
qui se réunissaient pour travailler sur
ces questions là mais est-ce que
réellement vous allez aboutir et quand
allez-vous aboutir et
parce que il se confirme que c'est très
difficile de construire des batteries
très lourdes pour ce type de véhicule
merci de m'éclairer c'est le cas
et s'il y a d'autres questions
madame aussi et nous aurons cette série
de questions et je vous donnerai
allez il y a vous êtes six donc 12
minutes pour les 6 ça fait deux minutes
chacun pour répondre merci
merci monsieur le Président merci aux
intervenants je crois que c'est
important d'avoir ce temps d'échange ce
matin
d'autant plus que lorsque nous parlons à
nos concitoyens de cet enjeu de la
mobilité électrique il y a effectivement
on observe une part de plus en plus
importante de nos concitoyens qui
souhaitent participer à cette transition
écologique et transition énergétique
mais beaucoup se trouvent quand même
pris de doute au regard de la situation
qu'on a décrite ce matin avec on l'a
bien compris une une avancée à marche
forcée au niveau européen sur cette
transition cette obligation qui est
faite au constructeur à un moment même
où on semble avoir des difficultés à
garantir l'approvisionnement en
électricité et des coûts acceptables
pour nos populations et nos
collectivités c'est un sujet qui
aujourd'hui est pleinement d'actualité
alors j'aurais puisque beaucoup de
choses ont déjà été dites peut-être
trois remarques brèves tout d'abord sur
le réseau des bornes comme ancien
président du syndicat départemental
d'électricité de Saône-et-Loire j'ai
effectivement été sensibilisé à ces
sujets est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
un
nous apporter un éclairage sur l'enjeu
de l'habitat collectif parce que
effectivement sur
le
la possibilité de recharger à domicile
pour ceux qui ont un pavillon c'est
assez simple on a évoqué beaucoup les
trajets mais pour les gens qui habitent
dans l'habitat social en habitat
collectif quels sont les efforts qui
sont faits à ce sujet est-ce que pour
les nous dire également un peu plus de
choses sur les plateformes
pour que chaque usagée puisse savoir
quelle est la borne la plus proche
à laquelle se connecter puisque il y a
pas forcément une plateforme unique et
donc quel est le moyen d'y arriver et au
moment où nous avons avec mes collègues
il y a quelques années envisager le
déploiement des bornes dans notre
département nous annoncer l'arrivée
d'opérateurs privés au niveau national
avec des réseaux propres et à ma
connaissance on les attend toujours
lorsque le privé envisage d'y aller
qu'il n'y va plus on peut s'interroger
sur l'équilibre économique de tout cela
donc est-ce qu'il y a une inquiétude qui
que semble d'ailleurs confirmer
l'augmentation des tarifs actuels la
deuxième chose c'est une petite question
pratique vous avez beaucoup dit qu'il y
avait des capacités de bornes
différentes et que selon qu'on va
seulement voir sa grand-mère tous les
jours à 5 km ou qu'on décide de
traverser la France on utilisera pas le
même véhicule est-ce que vous
réfléchissez éventuellement avoir des
bornes des pardons des des batteries qui
pourraient être additionnels ou qu'on
pourrait
additionner juste lorsqu'on part en
vacances garder le même véhicule mais
ajouter une capacité comme cela et puis
enfin
avec sa mécanique simplifiée la voiture
électrique nécessite un entretien
complètement différent de ce qu'il était
avec la voiture thermique donc quel est
le les conséquences envisagées sur le
réseau des garagistes et sur les coûts
de réparation je vous remercie merci
monsieur le Président moi j'ai comme
j'avais dans les derniers une question
un peu annexe hier nous avons eu un
débat important sur le la nécessité sur
le la possibilité pour la Commission
européenne d'interdire le plomb alors
d'après les auditions qu'on a eu près de
80 plus de 80% des des du plomb est
utilisé dans les batteries et que je
voulais savoir si dans le cadre des
évolutions le plan pourrait être
remplacé par autre chose où il reste
indispensable dans dans la fabrication
des batteries elle fonctionnement donc
de des voitures et deuxième deuxième
point je suis rassuré de savoir que
d'ici l'obligation totale rouler en
voiture électrique mais je serai mort
ne
sois pas ne soit pas pessimiste ne soit
pas pessimiste
la parole est à Madame
merci Président
permettez-moi de revenir à une question
fondamentale nous avons tous compris que
nous il y avait une marche forcée comme
l'a dit mon collègue
liée à la transition énergétique à la
transition écologique aux besoins de
décarbonisation mais on l'a évoqué à
plusieurs reprises tout le développement
de des voitures électriques est liée
quand même à l'extraction de métaux
rares notamment le lithium et si on
regarde dans toutes nos idéologies cette
transition elle est liée et bien plus de
responsabilité à plus d'écologie à plus
de développement durable or l'extraction
du lithium on a dit elle vient souvent
de pays très lointains et on fait que
l'extraction du lithium peut contaminer
les cours d'eau contamine aussi l'air
est liée à des transports en superancer
et et donc l'intérêt de base je me pose
la question puisque on voudrait être
indépendant du pétrole on voudrait
améliorer la qualité de l'air mais les
choix que nous faisons nous rendent
dépendant d'autres pays lointains et
n'améliore voilà vont polluer
l'air alors vous n'êtes pas sans savoir
qu'il y a justement des des recherches
en France et l'Alsace est concerné
puisque le fossérénant est identifié
comme une ressource possible moi je suis
sénatrice du Bas-Rhin et nous avons donc
des projets pas loin de Strasbourg au
nord de Strasbourg alors il y a eu des
études qui ont été faites et on sait que
pour extraire 6000 il faut pour extraire
une tonne de lithium il faut 6 millions
de litres d'eau
180 mg litres d'eau pour 1 g il faut 6
litres d'eau pour 1 kg de lithium il
faudra 6000 litres d'eau et pour une
tonne 6 millions de litres d'eau et pour
arriver au 3800 tonnes par an à terme il
nous faut un peu plus de 23 milliards de
litres d'eau et on sait que l'eau
deviendra un problème à
plus ou moins court terme sur la planète
donc moi je me pose vraiment la question
fondamentale de l'intérêt de vouloir
passer
à toute électrique est-ce que ça
correspond vraiment à une protection de
l'environnement et à une décarbonisation
qui sera qui ne sera pas compensée par
les par les méthodes d'extraction de
transport voilà c'est une question
j'imagine que on n'a pas tous les
réponses merci
merci bien je vais vous proposer de
répondre il y a une question à laquelle
répondu tout à l'heure qui était posé
par Didier mandeli c'est le paquage
véhicule les bornes pour favoriser
l'autoconsommation que pensez-vous de
cette suggestion voilà on va le donner
dans l'ordre vous allez Monsieur David
commencer pour deux à trois minutes
merci beaucoup
des bouts de question que je vais
essayer de répondre rapidement
peut-être un mot sur les territoires
ultramarins qui sont effectivement aussi
une priorité dans le cas du
développement
du véhicule électrique avec des
problématiques particulières qui sont
spécifiques à chaque territoire en
fonction notamment de sa taille on a pas
la même réflexion survécu électrique en
Guyane ou en Martinique ou en Guadeloupe
c'est des réflexions qui se font
notamment dans le cadre de l'élaboration
des programmations pures annuelles de
l'énergie qui sont spécifiques à ces
territoires et qui sont coélaborés entre
l'État et les collectivités on a les
dispositifs du coup enfin notamment dans
beaucoup de ces territoires le véhicule
électrique peut jouer un rôle
extrêmement important notamment parce
que dans un centre d'entre eux il y a
pas de déplacement
je dirais de très grandes distances
notamment dans les îles
notamment en Guadeloupe et en Martinique
les déplacements se font au sein de
l'île on a des dispositifs d'aide qui
sont spécifiques qu'on a notamment des
bonus à l'achat qui sont plus élevés
dans ces territoires pour pouvoir
refléter le coût plus important des
véhicules dans ces territoires et on a
aussi des problématiques réseau qui sont
spécifiques avec un travail important
avec EDF sei sur comment le véhicule
électrique
sincère dans ces réseaux de petite
taille
donc on a c'est vraiment un sujet
prioritaire pour nous sur la logistique
urbaine effectivement on a beaucoup
parlé de là dans cette table ronde de
voiture électrique et il y a également
des vulves des camionnettes électriques
qui sont très développés mais se
développe également gérer le poids lourd
électrique et de plus en plus
au salon de Hanovre qui est le grand
salon des poids lourds de la de le grand
salon poids lourd dans le monde les
constructeurs de poids lourds ont
présenté des gammes de poids lourds qui
couvrent l'ensemble de la gamme que ce
soit
je dirais les jusqu'au plus aux poids
lourds les plus lourds et au plus de 44
tonnes qui même ceux qui ne sont pas
autorisés en France et qui roulent dans
d'autres pays le le la mob électrique et
pas réservé aux voitures le poids lourd
se développe de plus en plus on a en
France enfin on a mis en place un
système d'aide d'un système d'appel à
projet pour pouvoir soutenir le
développement des poids lourds
électriques et aussi il y a pour le
panoramique des sujets de bornes
particulières on est en général sur des
bornes qui sont sur le réseau de
transport avec des très grosses
puissances quand on fait des hubs de
recharge de poids lourds donc on a tous
des particularités sur ces bornes de
poids lourds on est légère on est en
décalage dans le temps par rapport aux
véhicules en gros on a 5 à 10 ans de
décalage mais on est au début du
décollage du poids lourd électrique avec
un développement mais on est en sur le
je parle bien sur les poids lourds par
contre sur les vues les camionnettes là
on a toute la gamme les constructeurs
ont toute la gamme de camionnette
disponibles
merci monsieur le Président quelques
mots sur des notions que j'ai que j'ai
captées sur la question des durablement
des énergies renouvelables alors vous
avez beaucoup évoqué enedis mais je vais
prendre quand même ma part du fardeau ça
permet aussi de comparer les enjeux
c'est pas inintéressant mon collègue
d'enedis a évoqué que chez les
particuliers beaucoup de bornes
s'installaient sans augmentation de
puissance moi j'ai évoqué un besoin si
on sait utiliser intelligemment la
recharge de 2 à 4 gigawatts de puissance
électrique en France
dans la région nouvelle-aquitaine la
préfète nous a demandé collectivement
enedis et RTE de préparer le réseau pour
être en mesure d'accueillir 14 GW de
puissance d'énergie renouvelable à
l'horizon de 10 ans 14 gigawatts c'est
16 réacteurs nucléaires donc tout ça
effectivement ne se fait pas sans
investissement après le problème c'est
pas tant la durée des travaux qu'on
serait prêt à faire enfin il nous faut
18 mois 2 ans pour construire un nouveau
poste source avec enedis mais une fois
que la préfète a fixé cet objectifs on
doit le traduire dans un schéma il nous
faut deux ans dans le cadre des règles
applicables au plan et programme pour
faire une concertation préalable
évaluation environnementale pour faire
valider ce schéma et ensuite vous
pourriez me dire bon mais au moins les
projets qui sont inscrits dans le schéma
sont dispensés ensuite de tout cette
procédure mais non puisque en fait il
faut recommencer projet par projet à
refaire une concertation publique une
évaluation environnementale sur chacun
des projets on estime que pour des
projets de postes sources ou de ligne à
haute tension il faut 50 procédures pour
pour deux ans de travaux donc d'où les 7
ans qui sont opposés donc deux voilà
deux aspects ne pas sous-estimer quand
même le volume extrêmement important que
ça représente et donc des
infrastructures lourdes à concevoir et
derrière
des procédures qui qui sont aussi très
très longues
et là aussi lors de grandeur la
différence montre que finalement sur les
recherches véhicules électriques on est
probablement sur des choses plus
abordables pour terminer sur notre plus
positive aussi a été évoqué la question
des stockages tampons moi je vous les
signaler une un projet que je trouve
très intéressant qui a été développé
dans les Hautes-Alpes par le syndicat
d'énergie que RTU a accompagné
financièrement consistant à coupler une
station de recharge véhicule électrique
public il y a trois ou quatre bornes
avec une ombrière solaire et avec un
stockage tampon réalisé à partir de
batterie de seconde vie et là ça permet
de d'utiliser beaucoup de configuration
quand il y a du soleil on peut alimenter
directement les voitures s'il y a pas de
voiture en recharge on stocke
l'électricité et aux heures chargées du
réseau au lieu de tirer sur le réseau et
bien on décharge la batterie pour
recharger les véhicules qui ont besoin
d'électricité donc ça c'est deux types
de système intelligent qui permettent
d'évoquer beaucoup de choses recyclage
des batteries de seconde vie et capacité
à moduler l'appel sans que ce soit
visible pour l'utilisateur de la bande
de recharge et bien il va pouvoir soit
utiliser de l'énergie renouvelable
immédiatement disponible ou utiliser en
différé sans tirer sur le réseau c'est
des expérimentations qui me semblent des
modèles qui me semblent intéressants
généralisé chez les particuliers
peut-être aussi mais ça je laisserai
m'envoyer des Médicis en parler
merci
bien mais merci Monsieur bonnet parce
que vous avez dit beaucoup de choses que
je reprends tout à fait à mon compte et
notamment en réponse à madame la
sénatrice sur la situation très
particulière heureusement que c'est pas
le cas général du département de la
Charente de cette région
du front ouest ou effectivement le les
demandes de raccordement d'énergie
renouvelable
pose des difficultés
au réseau pour s'adapter alors est-ce
que c'est un manque d'anticipation sans
doute mais ce que je voulais dire en
renfort de ce que Monsieur bonnet disait
c'est que c'est une véritable cette
cette transformation est une véritable
révolution sur la structure même du
réseau et je donne cet exemple on a 2300
postes sources c'est-à-dire les postes
qui sont à l'interface du réseau de
transport et du réseau de distribution
et bien avec la le développement des
énergies renouvelables qui est tout à
fait évidemment souhaitable quand on se
projette à 2050 la majorité de ces
postes sources sont dimensionnés non
plus par la puissance appelée derrière
comme on avait toujours fait on avait
toujours dimensionné le réseau en
fonction de la de la demande d'énergie
que c'est que ces postes devaient
adresser et bien à 60 70 % ces postes
sources et ça sera évidemment le cas en
Charente ils vont être dimensionnés par
leur capacité de de
d'absorber l'injection des productions
locales évidemment cette capacité
d'absorption elle doit remonter aussi au
niveau du réseau du transport c'est ça
qui fait qu'il y a dans certaines
heureusement rares mais situation des
délais
lourds parce que les travaux très
importants de d'adaptation des réseaux à
tous les niveaux de tension je voulais
revenir effectivement sur le l'idée de
l'auto de l'autoconsommation à
développer et effectivement je me sens
bien et nous sommes nous aussi dans
diverses expérimentations on sent bien
l'intérêt qu'il y a à coupler et à
synchroniser la recharge d'un véhicule
électrique avec de la production
renouvelable au moment où elle se où
elle se matérialise puisque justement
tout l'intérêt de la du véhicule
électrique c'est que cette batterie est
une est un réservoir potentiel pour
accueillir j'allais dire la production
au moment où elle se produit donc
effectivement le cas d'usage des
ombrières entre midi et deux alors
peut-être plus souvent sur les les
parkings d'entreprise mais qui
permettent de recharger des véhicules
électriques c'est c'est effectivement un
des cas d'usage les plus les plus
intéressants puis je voulais revenir sur
le la question du résidentiel collectif
Genet a re mentionné pour dire
qu'effectivement donc on a on a un vrai
enjeu là-dessus puisque aujourd'hui
de l'ordre de 2% des copropriétés sont
équipés en infrastructures de recharge
partiellement mais en tout cas sont
équipés et il y a effectivement
maintenant je le redis
diverses solutions qui sont disponibles
pour ces copropriétés donc c'est une
bonne nouvelle on espère que ça va
permettre de de débloquer l'équipement
il y a la solution où on confie la
copropriété confie un opérateur privé
l'installation et il y a la solution où
elle elle confiait au gestionnaire de
réseau public de distribution le soin de
prolonger le réseau de distribution dans
le parking et là aussi avec maintenant
la possibilité de de faire préfinancer
ça c'est à dire de de ne pas avoir à
investir
up front ce qui va évidemment
complètement changer le la donne en tout
cas c'est ce que c'est ce que l'on c'est
ce que l'on espère
merci monsieur je vais vous m'interroger
sur ce que vous appelez la portabilité
financière ce qu'on appelle plus
couramment nous l'interopérabilité il
s'agit quand vous êtes en itinérance
donc on vous déplaçait d'un réseau à
l'autre de pouvoir vous assurer de vous
recharger par deux modalités soit une
recharge à l'acte que vous allez faire
avec une carte une carte bleue ou alors
plus souvent avec un
QR code et une application ou alors avec
une même carte d'un opérateur de
mobilité qui vous permettra d'être
reconnu de réseau en réseau cette
interopérabilité elle est obligatoire en
France depuis janvier 2017 pour donner
un ordre d'idée on avait près de 15000
points de recharge qui ont été installés
avant cette date donc 15000 sur les un
peu plus de 70 000 aujourd'hui donc
cette obligation n'a pas et ne pouvait
pas être respectée pour cela nous dans
le cadre du programme de financement et
de venir on a une cible spécifique de
modernisation de ses points pour
s'assurer qu'il puisse être rétrophité
et permettre notamment
l'interopérabilité mais il est vrai pour
une partie des réseaux qui ont été
déployés avant cette interopérabilité
n'est pas
n'est pas possible et c'est dans
beaucoup de cas des syndicats d'énergie
qui ont déployé de façon
précoce et ça a été une bonne chose pour
rassurer les premiers utilisateurs
déployer des réseaux de recharge
notamment bénéficiant du paysa de
l'ADEME jusqu'en 2000 2016
concernant le les véhicules de pour la
logistique je complète et je j'acqueste
tout à fait à ce que a dit Olivier David
effectivement aujourd'hui on a du côté
des constructeurs de de poids lourds des
stratégies d'électrification pour
quasiment l'ensemble d'entre eux avec
des des
perspectives de vente de 50% de leur
modèle en électrique d'ici 2030 sont
vraiment en train d'électrifier
entièrement la gamme on parle pas que de
petits poids lourds on parle également
de de véhicules qui permettront d'avoir
une autonomie de 500 kilomètres et de
surcharger en 45 minutes et donc on va
pouvoir aussi couvrir les le fret sur
des plus longues distances également
avec avec cette mobilité sur l'habitat
collectif je rejoins entièrement ce qui
a été dit par enedis on a une vraie
nécessité de permettre aussi aux
habitants de d'immeubles collectifs de
pouvoir se recharger on a un droit à la
prise qui existe pour des demandes
individuelles mais aujourd'hui et
notamment dans les copropriétés de plus
de 10 à 20 places on ne peut pas ne pas
réfléchir en infrastructures collective
déjà de prévoir des déploiements
importants pour s'assurer qu'on ait une
bonne adéquation avec le système
électrique et notre point de vue on ne
pourra pas réussir à à faire cette
équipement si on n'a pas des objectifs
des obligations qui sont fixés pour ces
bâtiments avec un calendrier à définir
évidemment et pour s'assurer qu'on est
bien des projets qui arrivent on va
avoir les incitations on a programmé
advenir qui qui couvre 50% des coûts on
a des dispositifs que ce soit de
pré-financement que ce soit
d'accompagnement sur les opérateurs
privés avec logivol ou même tout
simplement d'achat du du de
l'infrastructure et on va avoir besoin
de planifier l'ensemble de ces
déploiements et enfin deux points sur
les plateformes donc effectivement il y
a différents comme on peut la voir pour
planifier ces transports
en transport en commun ou ces
déplacements sur la route on a
différentes applications qui aujourd'hui
permettent de savoir où sont les bornes
de recharge et de prévoir votre votre
trajet en fonction de votre modèle de
véhicule et de la puissance que vous
avez au départ et vous souhaitez avoir à
l'arrivée je suis pas certain qu'il est
de volonté de de
d'avoir un monopole là-dessus mais les
constructeurs ont développé des
applications d'autres acteurs ont
développé des applications qui
fonctionnent très bien
et pour finir sur les réseaux privés
alors je suis pas sûr de d'avoir tout à
fait compris la question effectivement
les syndicats d'énergie ont déployé de
façon comme je disais précoce en avance
de phase des réseaux de recherche mais
aujourd'hui on a énormément d'acteurs
privés qui sont présents ça soit sur les
autoroutes par exemple avec des réponses
aux appels à projets des sociétés
autoroutières sur les parkings de centre
commerciaux on a également des acteurs
qui développent des stations de recharge
puissantes et très haute puissantes sur
en proximité de de nœud autoroutiers ou
à proximité de centre commerciaux je
pense qu'aujourd'hui sur les 40 enfin
38000 à peu près points de recharge qui
ont été installés depuis l'an dernier
sachant que les collectivités étaient
toutes impliquées dans des schémas
directeurs elles ont assez peu déployés
elles vont le faire je pense d'ici l'an
prochain pour ce que l'essentiel a été
fait par des par des réseaux privés
voilà c'est tout pour moi je vous
remercie
merci Madame Bouvier
alors pour faire suite à vos propos je
reprendrai l'offre de stellantis qui a
fait une JV avec eatolution qui est une
JV qui nous permet également de tester
ces infrastructures et on a un projet
qui s'appelle Atlant de développement de
bornes de recharge rapide avec des
solutions avec ombrelle photovoltaïque
et solution de stockage ça c'est pour la
partie recharge pour la partie recyclage
des et récupérations à utiliser du
lithium effectivement la récupération et
le recyclage du lithium consomme moins
d'eau et ça fait partie des intérêts des
installations
à venir et des investissements à venir
et des pistes pour nous avons moins
d'expérience que notre collègue Renault
sur ce sujet de du recyclage mais c'est
une voix qui est très très importante
pour le groupe silentis et puis
effectivement pour le pour le lithium
géothermale à bas carbone ce sont des
pistes d'exploration qui sont regardées
avec notre partenaire Vulcain Vulcan
tout à fait dans votre pays et dans
l'Est de la France
je terminerai sur les sujets du poids
des véhicules vous nous interpellez sur
le point de nos véhicules et le fait que
le on est produit des véhicules gros
chers
c'est exact nous avons des véhicules qui
sont qui ont grossi ces dernières années
et vous nous interpellez également sur
la rentabilité de notre entreprise
néanmoins cette rentabilité nous a
permis en contrepartie de faire beaucoup
d'investissements dans les territoires
de financer la transformation de nos
sites industriels de faire des
investissements en recherche et
développement qui nous emmènent dans
cette transition énergétique et de
rechercher des solutions durables ce qui
est très important en fin que vous nous
interpelliez sur le sur le fait
d'abandonner les petits véhicules ce
n'est pas le cas pour le groupe silentis
puisque nous avons un véhicule ami sans
permis à moins de 20 euros par mois et
puisque Fiat 500 et leader du segment A
avec un véhicule qui rencontre un
véritable succès et une véritable
demande de nos citoyens français sur ce
type de véhicule
enfin vous abordiez le sujet du coût de
l'entretien des véhicules qui
diminuaient nous prenons ça plutôt comme
une bonne nouvelle puisque ça permet de
diminuer ce que l'on appelle le TCO le
total que ça fenerchip le total le coût
du véhicule dans son usage et cela
participe à rendre l'équation du
véhicule électrique beaucoup plus
intéressantes pour nos clients et c'est
pour nous un point de positif
[Musique]
je vais faire très rapidement monsieur
le Président je vais essayer de répondre
à quelques questions d'abord le Cédric
sur les dromcoms effectivement c'est un
sujet il y a un sujet historique sur les
VHU les véhicules d'usage dans les 30
comme les deux constructeurs à Renault
et stellantis sont très investis dedans
et ont financé d'ailleurs les filières
de récupération à ce stade on a encore
peu de véhicules électriques hors
d'usage dans les temps de comme on y
travaille beaucoup sachez que c'est un
sujet sur lequel parfois on a des
problèmes parce que les batteries sont
considérées comme des déchets on
n'arrive pas à les rapatrier en France
pour les recycler donc moi ce que je
vous propose c'est qu'on travaille à ce
sujet là parce que nous-mêmes parfois on
est bloqué dans ce qu'on dans ce qu'on
souhaite faire dans le transport des
batteries pour le pour les recycler donc
voilà tout ce qui pourra nous aider à
améliorer cette filière là on en est on
est extrêmement preneur bon je suis pas
forcément revenir sur le recyclage du
lithium bien sûr c'est extrêmement
important et c'est ça qui nous qui
réduira aussi notre dépendance bien sûr
à l'extraction et il y a des pays
étrangers aussi et je voulais conclure
avec quelque chose la première chose
vous dire que l'usine de Flins elle est
à votre disposition pour être visitée
parce que vous voyez qui est beaucoup de
sujets qui sont qui sont voilà que qu'on
traitent là-bas et vraiment on sera ravi
de vous y accueillir et le dernier sujet
c'est effectivement bon le sujet des
petits véhicules j'y reviens pas Renaud
aussi en développement ce que je veux
dire sur la montée en gamme la montée en
gamme c'est vraiment majeur pour notre
industrie si je dois résumer le le
nouveau plan stratégique de Renault
c'est des volumes à la valeur des
volumes à la valeur parce que
il y a une empreinte écologique on sait
que produire en masse des véhicules
c'est plus forcément l'avenir on veut
rénover on veut améliorer la durabilité
de nos véhicules on veut développer des
services d'autopartage et monter en
gamme je peux vous dire il y a eu
beaucoup d'interventions sur la filière
automobile pour mieux partager la valeur
ajoutée il faut en créer et ça c'est en
montant en gamme qu'on aura plus de
valeur ajoutée à partager aussi dans la
filière automobile française c'est comme
ça qu'on sera moins courant c'est aussi
par des véhicules par des voitures qui
viennent de très loin
voilà merci
oui il me semble que personne n'a
répondu à la question de Nicole Bonnefoy
j'ai plusieurs questions mais au moins
une sur les microparticules liées au
pneu qui sont nettement plus importantes
en termes de pollution que la
motorisation parce que vous attaquez à
cette problématique
alors sur les microparticules mises au
freinage c'est ça alors oui en fait
c'est je suis pas un spécialiste du
sujet je suis désolé je pourrais faire
vous remonter des informations bien sûr
je crois que c'est beaucoup lié au poids
des véhicules donc forcément les
véhicules électriques sont sont un peu
plus lourds et donc il y a effectivement
des émissions de de particules au
freinage mais qui existe qui existe dans
tous les véhicules je veux dire voilà
alors nous on développe voilà on
développe des on essaie de développer
des c'est un sujet bien sûr qu'on prend
en compte puisqu'on essaie de traiter
toutes les émissions et on sait que
voilà c'est c'est une dimension de
véhicules électriques qu'on doit traiter
et on essaye de développer des modules
de freinage qui mettront moins de
particules fines mais de toute façon
c'est quand même une amélioration par
rapport à un moteur thermique
mais je vous ferai passer des
informations sur le sujet je le connais
pas
merci de merci de nous faire passer les
informations sur
surpasser les informations sur les
questions que poser Nicole Bonnefoy et
je crois qu'il y a une autre collègue
aussi qui
attend une réponse
j'attends aussi peut-être des
expressions concernant mais question
le bilan de l'extraction des métaux
rares et notamment du lithium qui
polluent les sols l'air et les os et
donc voilà quel est votre regard
j'imagine bien que
concernant les évidemment cette
transition elle est aussi intéressante
pour l'inflation elle est intéressante
sans doute pour beaucoup de de branches
industrielles mais le fond de la
question c'est bien
la transition
écologique la décarbonateisation donc
j'ai du mal à trouver
les solutions dans dans le véhicule
électrique merci
alors je ne pourrais pas vous donner les
chiffres de du lithium et le bilan
pareil je peux demander à mes collègues
et on vous remontera les données si on
les a
ce qui est sûr c'est que
donc ça pour la partie lithium
et puis pour le bilan économique la
question est posée par nos propres
présidents puisqu'on pose la question
sur l'ensemble de la chaîne et
qu'aujourd'hui on a pris cette
trajectoire de la transition énergétique
pour des raisons réglementaires et nous
n'avons malheureusement pas la réponse
et je ne l'ai pas plus que mon président
et peut-être en complément parce que je
pense que oui parce que je pense que
dans votre question il y avait une
dimension aussi assez fondamentale de de
questionner finalement cette cette
transformation du secteur du transport
vers l'électrique donc moi je ne suis
pas du tout un spécialiste de
l'extraction du lithium et donc de des
dommages à l'environnement que que cela
occasionne et que vous avez tout à fait
souligné mais ce que l'on peut quand
même dire c'est que sur l'urgence
climatique c'est à dire que sur le sujet
absolument crucial de réduire les
émissions
de gaz à effet de serre
à zéro en fait en 2050 et bien le
véhicule électrique là pour le coup à un
avantage qu'on peut on peut le prendre
dans tous les sens il a un avantage
clair sur le véhicule thermique donc je
crois que sur le fond
cette transition ne fait pas débat
surtout dans un pays
comme le nôtre où on a un mix
énergétique qui est déjà très décarbonée
mais mais ça n'enlève rien au fait que
il y a aussi dans cette industrie là des
procédés nécessaires qui sont polluants
en fait il y a plusieurs façons de
l'extraire et effectivement on travaille
avec des entreprises ma collègue a cité
Vulcan il y a différents projets pour
essayer d'extraire du lithium de façon
la plus décarbonée possible
enfin ça fait partie de nos priorités
dans nos approvisionnements on a trois
priorités c'est sécurisé nos
approvisionnements sécuriser les prix et
l'extraire de la façon la plus
responsable possible voilà sur le bilan
CO2 du véhicule électrique il fait aucun
il fait aucun doute en France un
véhicule électrique sur l'ensemble de
son club de vie y compris la production
de la batterie etc on est à 80% des
missions de moins maintenant les
services miniers comme vous le savez
c'est pas que des émissions de CO2 voilà
et donc on travaille tous ces tous ces
tous ces sujets là et le recyclage est
fondamental pour limiter le bilan aussi
environnemental de l'extinction c'est
pour ça qu'on est aussi on y travaille
avec autant de d'acharnement sur le
recyclage du lithium
merci merci pour pour cet intérêt je
vais je vais conclure parce qu'on a on a
encore une question à l'ordre du jour
pour désigner des rapporteurs pour avis
pour le budget merci de à vous toutes et
tous de votre participation merci pour
cette table ronde qui était riche parce
que il y a beaucoup de questions qui se
posent que ce soit en matière
d'alimentation en matière d'extraction
de matériaux en matière de
fonctionnement de comment on recyclera
les batteries
en matière économie circulaire n'est-ce
pas Martin je pense que il y a encore
beaucoup de questions effectivement on a
bien conscience que ce sera beaucoup
moins d'émissions de gaz à effet de
serre mais que des questions restent en
suspens qu'il faut qu'on les travaille
tous ensemble pour essayer de trouver
d'abord de répondre aux attentes de
celles et ceux qui vont équiper un
véhicule de permettre aussi de voir dans
quelle mesure on peut
accomp gagner les personnes qui devront
changer de véhicule dans le cadre des
zones affaiblissement parce que ça c'est
aussi important parce qu'il y a pas le
tout de dire ben vous pourrez plus
utiliser votre véhicule vous rentrerez
plus à Lyon ou je ne sais dans quelle
ville mais si ils n'ont pas les moyens
effectivement de changer leur véhicule
il faudra aussi un accompagnement
c'était une mesure qui avait proposé
fini de Tabaro et c'est important il a
rappelé la CMP qui était
non seulement 9 heures mais qui est sur
ce sujet a été un peu difficile
je crois qu'il faut vraiment qu'on
prenne conscience il y a un problème
au niveau routier d'émissions des gaz à
effet de serre on a on s'est fixé des
objectifs pour répondre à ces objectifs
et bien il faut chacune et chacun
d'entre nous essayons de trouver les
meilleures solutions les meilleurs
moyens d'y parvenir merci encore pour
votre participation merci pour vos
réponses et puis j'ai bien noté que
quelques réponses nous seront adressées
par courrier merci et je vais demander à
nos quitter la salle et je vais
rapidement j'ai simplement une informe
deux informations à vous donner sur les
rapporteurs pour avis voilà merci